so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to
round 11 here at the tata steel chess
tournament my name is fiona anthony and
i'm delighted to be joined once again by
grand master daniel neroditsky who dania
do my eyes deceive me or did someone get
a haircut on the rest day someone i
don't know who it was i mean i'm sure a
lot of people got a haircut i was indeed
among them the rest day was very good it
was i slept until noon and i'm not even
ashamed to say that
i feel refreshed and i am certainly
ready for more chess but fiona before we
get to that we have an unfortunate bit
of news to announce yeah unfortunately
and we'll pull up the official statement
unfortunately daniel duboff will not be
able
to finish this tournament after testing
positive um
or coronavirus in a pcr test yesterday
uh his results from prison swans will
stand though as he played more than
seven games
and while the remaining three uh games
those will be forfeited so today report
tomorrow pragnanda and during the last
round uh magnus carlsen they will get
the full point for those games that will
not be played in
of course a huge uh pity for the
tournament for chess fans and we wish um
daniela a very swift uh recovery
and uh dania
let's quickly see what happened here uh
two days ago which was a very very on a
very eventful round
it was unbelievably eventful it was a
round that lasted over seven hours total
we were exhausted the players were
exhausted but
this is what we're here to watch we had
a quick draw between sergey and magnus
and berlin shanklin and chakriar also
drew relatively quickly but man the four
decisive games fiona those were a sight
to behold especially prague's marathon
victory over his compatriot adventit
with the black pieces and fabby's
shocking defeat at the hands of rehard
report that was another excellent game
and of course niels pulling it out
against daniel dubov and another
marathon stronger and the last decisive
game andreas panko outplaying jordan
munforce in really really nice style
absolutely and what that meant for uh
the standings at the top it didn't
change too much magnus carlson still
half a point clear of anish giri
but
those are going to change a lot now
because remember magnus he is going to
get a full point uh without playing
against duboff uh in the last round
richard will get a full point today
um
so aneesh there's even more pressure on
him let's see who he's up against uh
today
indeed let's check out the pairings we
have we have duda shankland
we have van forest against gario that is
a magical touch
very good friends and rivals and what
aren't they as we have deals
versus essepenko
well report to above that game is of
course not going to take place that's a
full point for richard and i'm looking
forward to this one fiona ramesh against
caruana or a
prague against caruana
yeah and then of course again
yeah this is gonna be a big one with
magnus
looking to bounce here we see one result
is already unfortunately in the
standings uh richards will not be coming
to the playing hall so that game
will not even be started but elsewhere
magnus uh with that three point he now
knows he will get in the last round a
win today
uh with the white pieces against fidet
would be absolutely huge for him
it would be and of course vidic
suffering a very painful loss uh two
days ago against prague uh a position
you know very promising position out of
the opening you know i know he was
already tasting the top of the
tournament standings he is going to have
to recuperate put it behind him because
he has a very difficult task ahead of
him
for sure and well anish geary he is
another man that we will watch very
closely in the old dutch clash against
uh jordan van furies some more exciting
games elsewhere but dania tell us uh we
are going to have some fun here with
this one but it's not just us people
watching us at home can also get
involved in the action how do they do it
indeed it's not just us and please don't
forget to vote on the results of today's
games go to chess.com events navigate to
the tournament select a game click vote
and select your winner you could win a
piece of the 000 prize pool for best
voters or free diamond memberships
voting ends after the 10th move of each
game so don't procrastinate don't miss
out and remember to vote on all the
games at chess.com
events fiona indeed do it now
get involved try and get a piece of the
pie but we are going to back into the
playing hall with the camera as we see
at that table there once again wishing a
very swift recovery
for daniel of course a huge pity for
everyone but he is the main concern so
that game as we said will not take place
but elsewhere we see that some
players have already arrived for their
clash if you're wondering by the way
ratings will not be impacted so the
opponents get the full point but not not
any rating we see sam shanklin there
arriving for his game against of duda
and
is that neil surprisingly arriving even
before i see panko both of them are
usually early uh to the game
very punctual indeed yeah niels and i i
think are united in that quality i
remember um i was traveling with them to
a tournament in corsica
um and we were both we were trying to
catch the same flight from paris and we
were both playing we were both freaking
out about it so i can confirm niels is
someone who likes to be punctual
and so is yesterday
we see that neil says
perfect remember niels is having a word
uh with
leonard oates of course
um niels is now under uh for those of
you wondering he's being checked every
day by the tournament um doctor
of course not a great situation for him
he was sat across daniel dubo for almost
seven hours a couple of days ago but
we'll see
hopefully hopefully everyone can
conclude the tournament that it hasn't
spread for the pregnant arriving for
what there's a big game against fabiano
prague he will be feeling the high after
beating with it
while for fabiano uh it really really
hasn't been his tournament
yeah i mean it's an unpleasant game you
know he has black against prague who's
now confident and you know fabiano has
to stop the tailspin here and i just
wanted to add that it is an unfortunate
situation but at the same time the such
are the times you know we know that
something like this could occur and you
know i have to commend everybody for
handling it
very professionally the players the
organizers who make the best out of out
of a difficult situation so you know i'm
grateful that the other games are going
on
and we wish all of the other players uh
health throughout the tournament
for sure we're now into the final
weekend only three games to be played
here
uh to decide who is going to be the
champion of this year's tata steel we
see sam
looking around uh
at arriving yan shishtov do that it is
one minute to the start of the round
maybe even less we're seconds away uh
vidic just arriving for his clash
against magnus who as always fashionably
he's not at the board at 7 59 i can't
believe it all i guess what is it uh
what is what's time 159
in holland yeah 150 259.
the clock has just struck two
i think we can see the players are just
starting and with it
i think it's always like a i think yeah
no he's gonna start the clock and i
think there's absolutely um i think
overall while i appreciate the gesture
of rating for your opponent i think
um
starting the club is also absolutely
normal we see shah he is not waiting
for
uh sergey and i really think jonas is on
the player to to be in time
not on the opponent to wait for them
my rule is always if i see them in the
playing hall i won't start the clock if
i see them walking toward the board i'll
wait otherwise there's as you said
there's no expectation that just because
it's magnus
uh anyone is expected to wait and magnus
wouldn't like anybody to wait but you
can set your watch fight he will be here
40 seconds into the round
and someone's arriving there who is that
is he still in the background in the
back i don't see he will be coming from
the left side where the player's
entrance is the the man we see just
walking towards us there at the bottom
he's done a great job this tournament
not only is he one of our two arbiters
he's also the tournament doctor so he's
been working some long long hours a big
shout out
to him
and magnus not there yet we see vidit
getting up
from the board having a little stroll
while he
he waits uh for
four magnus to arrive
you know this is the best part of the
game
waiting for your opponent to arrive you
haven't made any mistakes yet uh you
know that for a fact because you haven't
made any moves you can watch the other
games um yeah he could uh you could get
used to this actually magnus is not the
only player who hasn't arrived yet we
see that jackie
is also walking around after making the
move one e4 waiting for for sergey uh
maybe they're still analyzing their game
from two days ago it was such a complex
affair
i think they're just the rest they
wasn't enough to
delve into all of its nuances
feverishly analyzing their hotel room
yeah magnus and sergey but magnet's
making it surprisingly first
and uh we are still waiting for sega i
know who has
uh just arrived to the two of them they
did conclude their analysis i was
serious yeah they came at the same time
this is too suspicious they were
definitely analyzing
um and i'm very curious to see
what happens in uh magnus vidit what a
pre you know with magnus it's always a
complete toss i mean he can play
basically any first move e4 d4 c4 and it
won't be a surprise
he is literally impossible to prepare
against
uh and
of course vidit is an opening beast he's
incredibly knowledgeable so very excited
to see what they're going to come up
with and we can take a quick look at our
bird's eye view
uh before perhaps returning to the
magnus game to see
what opening the world champion plays um
well we see a nimzo indian van forest
geary van forest flank a3 that's a very
combative line that's a game to keep an
eye on a slav and pragmatic carwana and
a london system into this game and there
we go yeah i like it we saw the london
system and the the bird's eye view is
swiftly removed
what do we think what do you think
danielle you have one second oh too late
i was gonna save four i was totally
gonna save for
and
forbidded i i think vidit has played
sicily and he's played e5 he's played
the karo khan
i i mean
you know he he also
has played a great diversity of openings
and e5 it's like he's played e5 maybe a
berlin
oh wow bishop c4 the bishop's opening
that's right is a very rare guess this
is actually for once danya they're
playing my repertoire nothing you know
okay nothing too theoretical some quick
development and attacking i'm a big fan
i'm a big fan of the bishop's opening
i've played this as well uh over the
board so this is this is fun now uh
don't count you know count your your
eggs when they've hatched as they say
because this still might transpose into
an italian uh fiona but we're both
cautiously optimistic but i was also
thinking because with it also plays the
petrov right so the bishop's opening
sometimes that is a a choice you can go
for if you want to avoid
the petrov
yeah and magnus going d3 this is not the
italian by the way to those
uh wondering bishop c4 straight away
without knight f3 is its own opening
and the reason uh it often does not
transpose into the italian is is that
white often delays the move knight f3
fiona and you know this better than i do
white can orient himself toward an early
f4 in a lot of lines my favorite move uh
in the world whenever i can get a pawn
to f4 this is literally my my pet i've
played nowhere near as many games as you
but uh
no bishop c4 it's a tricky little move
black has a few different ways in in
which they can respond of course but i'm
i'm curious what fit it is going to do i
think there is no way like there's a lot
of openings he could have expected today
but this won't be one of them
no and he's contemplating you know there
are many reputable ways to meet the
bishops opening
there is the move c6 here preparing a
quick d5 uh the i think the traditional
moves are bishop c5 and and knight c6 of
course just just developing pieces
uh but the bishop's opening it has a
bite you know it's not just something
you play to avoid theory it is a
reputable line and if black just kind of
stumbles around aimlessly
uh you know some of those positions
where white gets in early f4 and are are
genuinely dangerous for black so vidit
uh probably remembering remembering his
analysis and this is definitely caught
him off guard no question about it and
well magnus let's just talk about it one
more time with uh
duboff being out of the tournament i was
just talking with rick we were trying to
figure this out before going live but i
think if magnus wins today
and anish doesn't
don't take our word for it but i think
we're right about this if magnus wins
and anish doesn't magnus is at least
guaranteed to be in the playoff
for first and well with the white pieces
i think regardless of the duboff
situation magnus with the white pieces
would have gone
for the the win but here he's uh
he's really saying today i'm not so
interested i don't want to see any
opening debates let me just play
something that will surprise you from
the the get-go and
i'm not going to allow you to surprise
me somewhere in the with the opening
prep
that's what makes magnus so amazing you
know he's done so much to revolutionize
the game
uh and one of those items i think this
is not something that's often talked
about fiona it's it's his own ability
to shape-shift in the opening i mean he
can literally play anything he seems to
understand every opening equally uh
something that we take for granted but
wait a minute that that has never been
the case throughout chess history even
kasparov even the top players before
magnus's generation
uh it wasn't like this you know they
might have had a expansive opening
repertoire but it was still a repertoire
it was two three openings uh not 18
different openings and magnus
has pioneered this ability to constantly
surprise his opponents and somehow
uh be incredibly well prepared in
whatever
obscure line he chooses so i think this
is a great choice and again yeah if
magnus wins this game he basically wins
the tournament so uh he senses that this
is as good of a chance as annie's got
white against vinit uh and he is going
to be
very uncompromising in his approach and
danny i don't know if you can relate or
confirm but i look at with it and you
gotta feel almost sorry for him because
you know yesterday was a rest day he
will have invested
so many hours you know looking at all
the possible things that magnus could
play
and um i mean as i said earlier the
chances that any of those hours would
have gone to the bishop's opening is is
unlikely
yeah it's a very frustrating sensation
particularly if he had cooked up uh an
interesting variation against what he
had expected so you know he's got to
recalibrate and now he's got to remember
his analysis
and he knows that magnus has probably
spent three hours yesterday
reviewing uh his his lines which is an
even more frustrating and disquieting
sensation so
uh david i think correctly
slowing it down making sure that he's
going down the right path and he has
played
knight c6 to which we're probably going
to see knight c3
yeah so magnus if i'm not trying right
he could go knight f3 oh no he goes
knight f3 i'm so disappointed
[Music]
into the italian okay that's so lame
why did he initiate that whole thing i
mean he might was he afraid of the
petrov maybe maybe he was afraid of the
petrol yeah maybe that's the reason yeah
yeah
i'm pretty sure that that's what he was
trying to avoid he was never actually
planning to play the bishop's opening
that's a clever
very clever choice
i'm sure reddit is relieved by the way i
think vidit you know was probably
worried that that magnus had actually
prepared something within the bishop's
opening he counted our blessings too
soon we jinxed it
and
i wonder even if magnus like it's hard
to know who is the happier one in this
gamble because
if uh vidit had gone c6 which as you
pointed out is one of the main lines
against the
the bishop's opening then we wouldn't
get back into
wouldn't get back into yeah in italian
but but magnus has just played knight c3
which is
not the main line i mean everybody plays
c3 now that's the traditional italian
knight c3 is a kind of
weird four knights defense i mean bishop
c4
when i'm black here and they go knight
c3 i always feel like okay that's
already
a mistake more or less i go d6
there you go bishop g5 h6 g5 and black
is already
borderline better right so i'm curious
what magnus has cooked up
you want to be very careful if you're if
you're playing white uh to allow this
before black castles because black will
definitely go for this and this bishop
is
extremely bad it's just out of
commission
so in these types of situations
generally i've seen the bishop go out to
e3
and black responds often with bishop b6
and we could have the a very symmetrical
position bishop b6 bishop b3 i've had a
lot of blitz games with icaru in this
exact variation and he usually puts his
bishop on e3 and then aims for a quick
d4 we'll see
uh how the world champion handles this
i'm happy i mean i was disappointed when
i saw knight f3 appear but now knight c6
and knight c3 at least that's going to
be something more lively
than than the usual c3 also something
new so we're looking forward to this
shall we bring back the the bird's eye
view and have a look um elsewhere
why not
uh so we have well we have a very
interesting opening brewing in the uh
van forest
geary game shall we perhaps go to that
one
sure before we go there actually danya
can i ask you very quickly because i see
a lot is happening between my mediaerov
and karjakin but the two have a history
of being of having made some uh draws
before but this looks crazy is this
theoretical or
or is it just crazy
almost definitely theoretical i mean
we'll definitely go to that game maybe
after uh
let's take a brief look at the jordan
game
i think it's theory to answer your
question and try to think it is theory
but we'll take a look
um in the yard again the reason that
caught my eye is because we don't see
the sameish variation of the nimzo very
often anymore
and that's the immediate a3 essentially
forcing a trade
and the id white's idea is to say yes
you know i'm damaging my pawn structure
but i'm going to go for a quick f3
e4
and giri playing one of many many viable
lines here b6 knight c6
and the idea of behind black setup is to
pile up
on this c4 pawn as quickly as possible
and yes white does allow
black does allow white to play e5 but
this is less dangerous than it appears
because the knight can simply reroute
through e7 or even h6 and it's premature
so jordan
going bishop d3 bishop a6 and
queen e2 and now if memory serves me
right and i'm checking the opening
reference now knight b3 is a move here
uh rooting out the bishop as is uh d6 so
jordan's still playing instantly but
anish taking the first
uh serious think of of the game
and
um well maybe you can tell us a little
bit again about the the plans uh for
either either side
well generally black black is still
going after white's queen side so the
reason you you see d6 first of all it
discourages e5 and anisha's just played
it
and give it given time let's just make a
couple of random moves for white
uh essentially there's two ideas one is
to go c5 rook c8 and and then take on d4
but the main idea is to go queen d7
and then either queen a4 or queen c6
uh and hit the c4 pawn one more time
so here after rook b1 there's still a
couple of games in the database if you
play the immediate queen c6
uh you run into rook b4 so you can see
that it's a battle for the c4 pawn and
if white wins that battle what is the
significance of that well the
significance of white winning that
battle is that white's hands are now
untied for action on the king side i
mean white can play f4 e5 and fiona if
black castles into it
you can just see how dangerous this
could be i mean white's got a tremendous
attacking potential on the king side
with that bishop aiming on h7 of course
i'm i'm approximating this i'm not
saying that these specific moves are
likely but black has to be extremely
precise in how he goes about
attacking the queen side and
simultaneously trying to prevent uh
white from developing an attack on the
king side so f4 is possible here
uh and knight h3 is also a possible
possible move as is bishop g5 so an
expansive menu of options we'll see how
jordan handles this but yeah very
ambitious approach jordan who uh had a
tough loss before the rest day against
isipanko i don't know how many draws has
he he's only made two draws i believe
out of the first
10 games two or three i think only maybe
two
um
and today well this is a position which
definitely has potential at least from
these early stages to to end decisively
it really does uh this is an exciting
game and we'll keep a very close eye on
it and speaking of exciting games
let's swing on over to
uh shakur's game against sergey
yeah so let's go from the start here
yeah well this was a scotch
gambit well no i don't know what this is
called d4 e takes d4 e5
i guess it starts out as a scotch gambit
um this listed as the center attack but
whatever it is is a popular very popular
line
uh d5 is is the typical response counter
attacking the bishop
this is all very standard theory there's
thousands of games in this position
bishop g4 bishop g4 is not the most
common
generally black castles first but okay
bishop g4 h3 bishop h5
bishop comes out to e3 to reinforce the
d4 pawn
castles and here the move g4 is
exceedingly rare queen c2
is the most common move by a country
mile queen c2 bishop g6 and now queen b3
and this position i'm familiar with
fiona g4 i've never seen before that's
extremely committal after bishop g6 he
combines this with castle short that is
modern chess in a nutshell you go g4 and
then just like any civilized human you
castle on that same side of the board
but i'm not surprised that shakira
tries
something
like this because if we bring back the
bring up the standings for one second
actually the only player at the top of
the standings who's really impacted by
uh duboff being out of the tournament is
shakia because he played the game
against duboff and that was a draw so he
lost half a point there while all the
other top four players magnus anish and
report are all going to get that walk
over point uh against duboff so shakira
mamedyarov today he is pretty much in a
in a must-win situation if he wants to
fight uh for the title here
that's a great point and this definitely
explains this kind of opening choice i
mean when you need to when you have a
muslim situation flying sergey is one of
the the worst pairings you could have
because of how incredibly solid he is so
this opening option makes sense now in
terms of how black can try to punish
uh white for castling on that side of
the world the move f5 comes to mind this
is
uh the engine likes this as well at
least initially
and in the event of on busan black can
recapture with the queen you can't take
the d5 pawn because f3 is hanging
and the typical response for white is to
take on c6
and then to vacate the e5 square for his
knight i wonder if they're actually
going to follow this this path and then
black and go queen h4
i wouldn't go into something like this
even probably with preparation but
you know chakriar is a one-of-a-kind
player
and uh this is what he's known for this
kind of
incredibly daring uncompromising chess
this is why we love him that's for sure
and dania i'm curious what are your
thoughts on this i i was just thinking
i'd be very curious if i was a fly on
the wall for example in the room of
jacques
this morning when the players found out
that duboff is out did i wonder if that
changed his preparation maybe quite last
minute let's say yesterday the players
for sure spend a
considerable amount of the rest day
preparing for the the next day game
then they wake up the year duboff is out
i wonder if then this morning shaq gave
his
we've got to to mix it up
cook me up something you know something
with a little more tabasco sauce on it
and uh you know that's not out of the
question because you hear some stories
of that happening you hear you know i
remember grishok telling a story like
that well i just woke up and uh
i was planning to play berlin but i
decided that it was not enough sag life
and so i played
uh neither simply decide the spur spur
of the moment as they say in english uh
but this happens and these
players are human not everything is
totally immaculately planned the night
before sometimes they have a flash of
inspiration uh and this was something
you know this line may have been
something that tracker airhead had
cooked up before the tournament so he's
not just pulling this out of thin air
yeah
i think that's a a very fair point but
this game here
uh definitely is shaping up um
to be very exciting as well
sergey taking some time
well at least he's following his prep
that's for sure shall we go back to the
the bird's eye view
let's do it
yeah hashtag grishok squad
typing that in the chat this is what i'm
busy with instead of actually
commentating the games we see that
jordan by the way has indeed gone f4
which is very natural and understandable
yeah we have that london system in
duda's game we have a an old school rye
lopez in uh grindelius yesterday if you
know i'll give you the choice you want
to go to prague duda
uh maybe we should check out reports
game that's
a pretty rich position there
sorry that was low-hanging fruit
let's start with grand alias against
jesse pankwood and
let's do it um okay well this is a rye
lopez
and
uh neil's opting for
the move d3 which is uh the sort of most
popular sideline rookie one being
the main line okay so andre responding
very traditionally b5 and d6
c3 and essentially you know uh yasipanko
playing at chagoran
setup which is still a very viable line
against d4
so this type of setup with knight a5 c5
and niels going d4
queen c7 and d5 and here's what's
interesting about this position fiona in
the main line with rookie one you could
essentially get the same position
with the only difference being the
placement of the rook so b5
bishop b3 d6 c3 castles h3
uh and if black plays the chagoran
one of white's main continuations is to
lock up the center with d5 this is uh
considered one of the most reputable
lines so if you compare this position
to this position
i'm just going to switch back and forth
a couple of times you can see the only
difference
is that the rook on f1 now who does this
favor well the tempting answer would be
black and it probably does favor black
but uh this i think is a very annoying
line for black with the rook on e1 so
because the center is so closed one
tempo fiona often does not make uh a
night and day difference
i actually
i'm still looking at the screen like i
was still this is like a magic trick
you've just shown i was trying to figure
out
where did that tempo you know it's like
you made the
rabbit disappear or something right
yeah i'm pulling it out continuously
pulling it out of the hat
um and and knight c4 by andre which is
uh they're you know dairy gore in these
types of positions because if you don't
play that
uh if you just sort of develop your
bishop for example
the knight gets totally excommunicated
with b3 uh and and then you're gonna
have problems with that knight for
really for the rest of the game
and you know this is a a classic
position in the sense that you know
white generally plays on the king side
and white typically plays on on the
queen side
as for typical ideas i mean the good
thing about having the rook on e1
is that white has this knight d2 f1 g3
maneuver which is
uh incredibly important in order to
assemble pieces on the king side and
niels might end up playing rookie one uh
you know anyway that's not out of the
question
very
interesting stuff i'm still this game is
uh
can you
danielle just have to sorry where did
that tempo this what's the short answer
as to where it is
because he ended up playing d4 whereas
in the main line you spend this tempo
playing rookie one and then you go see
three d4 and one fell swoop
of course and niels uh
hasn't gone
uh rookie one instead going b3
yeah chasing the nightwing i mean he
could still go rookie one
he could he could play a little bit on
the queen side himself i've seen people
go a4 and trying to lock up the queen
side with a5
or you could start with uh knight knight
b to d2 so again when when the center is
closed like this uh a single move
might not have tremendous significance
it's more about the the scheme
and the the system of peace placement
that you're adopting more rather than
individual moments that are important
and
niels has just made another move again
it wasn't rookie one but bishop e3
okay getting his bishop out first and
that makes sense i mean he doesn't want
the bishop to be locked in
when he plays knight bd2 my guess is
that he's still in his preparation i
think he still
knows what he's doing he had this
position at home yeah i think also
neil's a huge expert in the rory lopez
from
both sides remember everyone he was also
part of team
carlson for a couple of matches so i'm
sure they will have spent maybe a couple
of hours looking at
some stuff in the roy lopez let's move
on from here now and uh dania do you
want to start with prague or duda
yeah let's go to prague's game and i'll
just mention that uh
shakira and sergey are indeed
for now going down that line sergey did
play f5 and shakaria took on passant but
let's check out prague's game
against fabi they have an interesting
and a potential repetition
by the way so let me quickly walk
through
this game from the start we had a
semi-slav
prague going e3 and
after queen c2 bishop d6
there is a line called the maron
and the maron happens when white plays
bishop d3 black captures on c4
and then strikes on the queen side with
b5 this is an exceedingly sharp line
prague though deviating from that and
going for a much quieter system the move
b3 this is an anti-moron because if
black takes on c4 obviously white will
capture
with the pawn and that takes you know
the sting out of that idea
so
you know essentially baby just develops
castles bishop b2b6 castles bishop b7
and this is a very a very peaceful and
and positional line of the slavin that
is evidenced by the fact that they're
kind of playing on queensland a4 a5
prague repositioning his bishop to d3
maybe eyeing the move e4
and fabi staking his bishop onto that
outpost on b4 and
uh fiona the sort of obvious knee-jerk
continuation would be knight back to a2
that the potential
yeah yeah essentially this forces bishop
d6 because i don't think bishop a3 i
mean maybe bishop a3 is possible
i mean first of all i'd be quite scared
to play it although it doesn't seem that
the queen is going to get trapped but
i'm not sure that black benefits you
know in the event let's say c takes d5
he takes d5
uh the knight can return back to c3 and
then rook fe1 i don't think the trade of
dark squared bishops necessarily favors
black so
first of all we'll see if prague plays
this and then we'll see
whether fabi is just testing him or
whether he's genuinely fine with the
draw which is also not totally out of
the question yeah so i was thinking
about that while we were going through
and you mentioned the possible
repetition
it's really hard to say right because
fabiano of course on paper there is a
huge rating gap between the two players
but fabiano is playing with the black
pieces he's coming off a tough loss
prague is coming
on a a big high
and
i think it's just hard to know you can
never really put yourself in fabiano's
shoes how does he feel
does he really want to get a win here
does he just want the tournament to be
over with what would be your stance if
you were playing on the black side here
i i feel like fabi
you know he he was definitely very
frustrated after the last game
he's blundered uncharacteristically at
several points this tournament so it
again as you hint it at it's possible
that he's just saying you know this
isn't my tournament i want to limit the
damage and
i'm going to play very solidly with
black and then you know keep trying to
win the game win games with white even
though he's lost two games with white
pieces this tournament
impossible to say and it remains to be
seen i don't i don't recall the last
time someone players like fabio first of
all they barely lose
classical games uh at all but especially
not with
with the white pieces and prague well up
until this moment he had played every
move pretty much instantly we will see
here does he go for knight a2 if he does
what does fabiana do
but let's just update
the last quick look at the last game we
haven't seen yet
yeah let's have a look at duda shankland
and already a big time disparity in that
game
as i looks like sam sam has once again
demonstrated exquisite preparation he
has equalized completely out of the
opening now
how did this all happen well this was a
london
sam going with the e6 followed by c5
line
after knight bd2
i mean the vast majority of people go
knight c6 here's sam
playing a far less common move queen up
to b6
hitting the pawn on b2 and he wants to
take that pawn so duda defending it with
rook v1 and now bishop d6 interesting
way to prepare bishop d6
due to after a long thing deciding to
trade on d6 and
trade on c5 i'm not sure
what it is that he's
really hoping to achieve here he goes c4
but my question fiona is you know let's
say sam just castles
i don't see
any advantage for wine i mean i guess
black does have
one issue to resolve which is the light
squared bishop but he's going to resolve
it i mean one way or another either to
refine keto or through the move e5 at
some point this is not a concern for
black this is completely equal i i
really
i'm not not seeing the zest here in
induced
he almost looks
disappointed maybe he's thinking
this was too easy to to equalize out of
the opening i wanted more of a challenge
i wanted more of a preparation challenge
he's definitely a surprise you can tell
the way dude is handling this
yeah and i'm curious what it is that has
happened here because duda is the one
who's been spending all his time and as
you're saying it looks like
sam doesn't have
too many problems here to to solve once
that once that bishop gets developed
yeah i guess the only
thing to decide is whether he goes
knight c6 or castles now that's all i
was gonna say is he he has to be
obviously careful in these
positions you know as long as he does
have this problem with the bishop
we will leave him to it for now uh we
are gonna go for our first quick break
of the day but we'll be back here with
all the action from round 11 in just a
couple of minutes so we'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to round 11 here
at the tata steel
chess tournament if you're just joining
us now a quick reminder daniel duboff
unfortunately tested positive
four kovitz so he is out of the
tournament he will not be playing his
remaining three rounds and we wish him a
speedy recovery but dania elsewhere
there's a lot happening today
indeed fiona there is and starting from
our top left you can see magnus
embroiled in a kind of
weird italian against david that's a
game we're going to take a close look at
uh to the right of that we see jordan
van forest in a samish nimzo against
geary and giri has indeed put his queen
on a4 as is the tradition in this line
uh mamidyarov and karjakin are following
the line that we outlined that queen on
h4 that looks terrifying for white but
definitely still preparation no question
about it
uh for um
for chakrillar we have a rue lopez in
grandelias esapenko the center closed we
have that quiet slav
as prague refraining from knight a2 and
instead going rook a to c1 and
a pretty insipid uh london system in due
to shanklin but that game can definitely
heat up uh fiona i'm thinking maybe we
can return to the magnus game and then
kind of take a tour around all of the
games yeah i feel like they're almost
nicely aligned today like if we just go
clockwise we start at the top left
corner
and uh yeah so let's dive back into
magnus against it
so with it going h6 h3 a6 just sort of
uh
moving pawns around
a4
by magnus stopping stopping b5 uh d6
bishop e3 and now interestingly
because vidiq played a6 he has
a bit of difficulty i mean moving the
bishop back to b6 doesn't make any sense
anymore because now you have to ruin
your pawn structure that's out of the
question
sometimes you'll see people playing
bishop a7 but
again white can
probably take and then you have to take
the rook which is also very awkward and
white can strike with d4
so vidit ends up taking on e3
and after bishop e6 magnus uh not opting
for the symmetrical structure but
instead going b3
once again saying i'm happy to trade the
bishops but i'm doing it on my own terms
and i don't think that it is going to
take on c4 that's a very bad move
positionally because
it allows white to clamp down
permanently on the d5 square
and as long as the f file is semi-open
white has
uh you know guaranteed play on the on
the king side
particularly associated with this knight
maneuver from h4 to f5 so vidit he might
play d5 here i'm you know that looks
like a very natural move to me or he can
castle
and keep the tension but something tells
me magnus is still in his preparation
yeah and such an uncomfortable situation
for vidi to find himself in he is
already has spent a lot of his clock
time i think he is
and
going to be spending a lot more
you we talked about taking on c4 we
talked about that d5
can we also i guess just castling is
also an option or
yeah i mean castles castles might happen
but the thing is ultimately you're gonna
have to make a decision about whether
you're playing d9 if you don't play d5
i mean you can migrate this knight you
can play knight e7 here i like this move
because this prepares d5 and it also
prepares
to get the knight to g6 now white can
try to beat black to the punch with
knight h4
and now the engine suggests an
interesting idea why don't we go c6 here
and try to punish white for for playing
b3 now d5 is a threat and amazingly
there is the possibility of an exchange
sacrifice here on f6
but it doesn't appear to lead more lead
to more than a perpetual bishop e6 fe 6
queen g4 chuck looks very scary but
after king f7 black is threatening to
consolidate so white kind of has to
repeat moves i mean of course that's
very unlikely to happen but uh it shows
how rich these positions
uh can be with that undefined center a
lot of stuff can happen i just have a
lot of directions quick question at the
end of this line after the first check
on g4 when we went king f7 what if the
black
king tries to instead of going to f7 if
he goes
uh let's say yeah to h7
yeah i think white just takes on e6 and
then goes rook f1 it's sort of long-term
compensation uh there isn't anything
immediate it's just that the f5 square
is now extremely weak and if black ever
moves the knight away from east from g6
then white's knight
jumps into f5 and d6 this week this is
probably not worth going for
uh for black and vivid did indeed
uh castle short and i think magnus is
going to reciprocate
very
shortly
well this line looked tempting actually
that you just showed with knight d7
let's have maybe a quick look as well at
the alternative the immediate d5 euro
thing yeah the immediate d5 is
perhaps more natural
but if you think about it okay so if we
have a big trade on d5
um so it takes everything
you know white could play a move like
knight h4 here
and this is a very deceptive position it
looks extremely peaceful it looks like
black is under absolutely no danger
but you know white's pieces come into
the queen side very very
quickly now i've queen g4 so black has
to be quite careful
uh in these types of positions maybe
it's worth playing 97
and preventing knight f5 so it's pretty
clear to me that magnus is taking this
approach where he's definitely playing
for a win
uh but he's not willing to take any huge
risks and you know this type of position
magnus never loses so i think he's
basically saying okay if vidiq plays
very very precisely in the early middle
game the game is going to be likely to
end in a draw but uh in an unfamiliar
position with it
might not make the correct decision and
he's burning a lot of clock uh trying to
sort all of this out
yeah and i think i really like magnus's
approach here today once again we talked
about it earlier he's really making use
of of this range of openings and moves
he can play with the opponents never
knowing what to expect magnus indeed in
the knot like this thinking pose and we
actually had a result we completely
missed the daniella the players
are already gone
and we remember
curi and
well sam looked surprised and this is
even more surprising
a draw agreed duda offering a draw
after c takes d5 and
my goodness i mean well this is quite an
understandable decision in this position
he's totally symmetrical white has
absolutely nothing i'm still a little
surprised i mean
you know i think duda would probably
fancy his chances even in an equal
position but you know it could be a
million different things he could have
woken up on the wrong side of the bed
and said you know i'm not feeling great
today
you know let's just wrap this wrap this
game up let's again it's important not
to forget that these are human beings
yeah i mean it might be 27.60 but yeah
i was gonna say it
almost certainly
i think there might be something
happening behind the scenes that we
don't know because yeah
he's such a fighting player i don't
remember him yeah i mean i almost have
zero memory of him making a draw like
that especially with the white pieces so
um we don't know we don't know if we'll
hear if we've had interviews with the
players but
uh for some definitely a great result i
mean with the black pieces and
getting a free health not a free health
point but pretty much
sam is going to be very happy with
himself and good preparation you know he
uncovered this rare line queen b6 bishop
d6 and this is this is who sam is you
know he has
lines against everything he's almost
impossible to surprise
uh and and that's an incredibly valuable
skill at this level he has proven his
ability to survive and thrive against
against the very top players in this
tournament even though maybe not the
performance that he would have liked
yeah but uh still i mean he's really
shown what he's capable of um so well
two games over that leaves us with five
games but daniel i think we're going to
have to go back to shakira media and
yeah
yeah they're blitz they're continuing to
blitz out moves and
yeah once again just to show the line
that they just went down
um sergey did opt for f5 after a pretty
short thing so on poisson queen f6
bishop takes c6 in order to
uh
uncover the e5 square for the knight
sergey leaping into h4
now we have a trade and chakra has just
played
king h2 defending
the h3 pawn and as impressive as black's
pieces look i guess white's point
is that it's it's quite difficult to
find a follow-up and let's not forget
the bishop on b6 is not
the best-placed bishop yeah it's
pressuring d4 but d4 is very well
protected by the bishop and the queen so
i think shakur is kind of saying yeah
this looks ugly but in the long run he's
got all the positional assets he's got
the better pawn structure uh he's got
the pressure on the c pawn
and uh he can chase the bishop out of e4
with the move f3 so a very interesting
approach taken by shakur here kudos i'm
i like this kind of play yeah i well i
understand what you're saying in the
long term they're all these terms what
about the the short term do we not have
to as white this looks a little bit
scary to me
um
i i was even
i was trying to look as black and i
immediately try and come with some h4 h5
sadly doesn't work i guess because
because what actually h5 is interesting
no h5 is definitely viable knight g6 is
impossible
uh that's covered
it's not so easy i mean
white can't really move his queen now
because you're gonna go h takes g4 so
it's also quite difficult for white to
make a move rook g1 walks into checkmate
rook takes f2
uh so this is a completely viable
candidate move i mean f4
is the engine suggestion which is not an
easy move to play that means leaving the
bishop
on these this eternal outpost um but the
point is white wants to trap the queen
on h4 with the move g5
uh if you play the immediate g5 by the
way
i believe that there is
oh wow there's c5
and if d takes e5 bishop takes c5
and it turns out that that white bishop
is
fulfilling a very important job of
defending the f4 square and white's
position collapses here
i mean this position is really quite uh
crazy and i i'm i'm curious what black
maybe h5 is too
just too weak weakening for for black as
well because um i want to of course
check made the opponent's king but if i
fail then i've opened myself up for for
no reason
yeah it's the middle for sure sergey
should
should proceed in this position
i mean you can move the queen back to
e7 uh in order to prepare c5 if black
can get c5n all of his problems are
going to be solved the point is if
knight takes c6 this is a case in point
black sacrifice is one pawn but this
shows the double pawns can actually be a
tremendous asset here comes the other
pawn c5 this undermines the knight white
is in mortal danger in a position like
this so
on queen e7 white can consider going
rook c1 except here's the catch this
doesn't actually stop c5
uh because again the knight on e5 is
constantly hanging
in the event of d takes
uh c5 so queen e7 is
the preferred move by the engine and it
also happens to be very logical to
prepare c5 uh but something tells me
chakra has factored this into his
preparation yeah i was just gonna
say that i i feel i find this is a
position that
i find so hard to evaluate and to
understand like if you ask me who would
you rather be and i think at the end of
the day my
answer would be i would rather be the
player who has looked at this
uh before and if uh if there is one of
them it's definitely not karjakin who we
see there in deep default while as you
said very likely he's had um this to a
very similar position on the board
i see some people in the chat suggesting
another very logical move rook ae8 and
it's funny this actually creates a
hidden threat let's make a random move
for white
rook takes e5 d takes e5 bishop takes e3
and at the end of this line the rook
swings on over to f2 with checkmate
uh so rook 88 will probably necessitate
the move f4 you have to support the
knight
um instead of instead of a4 you have to
play four
but again in the long run you know white
consolidates queen d2 rook c1
if you think about it black's position
is full of full of weaknesses and pieces
that could end up
uh becoming pretty significant
liabilities so sergey i think is it's
totally understandable why he's so deep
in thought
for sure very interesting stuff here
we'll come come back here but shall we
go back to the dutch clash between uh
jordan van ferece and anish geary
absolutely let's have a look at
how that game is proceeding and oh my
goodness anisha with an hour and three
minutes to jordan's hour and 38.
that is just crazy
that really is crazy actually
while we catch up with the games where
do you think do you think the whole
opening just what came as a surprise
here as anish who he played the nimzo as
black where do you think that jordan
surprised him
e3 i mean i'm pretty sure it's on the
fourth move and again i really have to
emphasize that the same-ish variation is
it's incredibly rare at this level it's
not that it's considered bad it's just
it's just not fashionable i mean i i
think if magnus were to be playing it
regularly it would enter it would
re-enter fashion but
it's just often considered a little bit
too risky because you can see
how potentially
uh you know white's structure could end
up collapsing but jordan i think this
was a fantastic choice and he's
definitely playing for a win in this
game knight f3 queen a4 and just in time
he brings his knight back to d2 and not
only does he defend the pawn he also
defends
the b3 square
so
again for anish the question is not just
how does he continue the pressure but
what does he do because jordan is now
very seriously threatening the move e5
and with all of black's pieces you know
on on a mission
on the queen side black center and
kingside is tremendously vulnerable and
anish has to tread very very carefully
here
and danya well we are seeing the the top
engine line which is being suggested to
us
which is a move that is madness madness
knight g8 preemptively that's ridiculous
and then you know casually maneuvering
the knight in this position to e7
man and castling long fiona is not just
not out of the question but maybe
likelier than castling short
this game is uh
insane i mean we've got some really
really
uh exciting this one the the shahriar
game i have no idea what's going on but
uh
anish he has been caught by surprise and
i think he's already finding himself in
a very unenviable position
yeah he doesn't like these types of
stitching i mean who likes to be caught
off guard but anish in particular
prides himself on his
very extensive opening knowledge and
yeah he's not he's not feeling great let
me i guarantee you of that i mean he can
cast along immediately that's another
option
but this doesn't solve all of black's
problem it's not like the king here is
that safe you know white can go rook b1
rook before
and black can essentially bid goodbye
to any hopes of winning the c4 panel if
the king is on that side of the board
you're never really going to be able to
go c5
yeah not an easy
not an easy task none of the castles
look too appealing i'd be shocked if
anish actually went for nightshade so
i'm very curious to see what is he going
to do
but we will come back here
let's quickly bring up the bird's eye
view
and see what updates we've had elsewhere
yeah well we we have bid it over on the
top left side of your screen he has
indeed gone d5 and we see that train on
d5 magnus
contemplating his next move in a niche
by the way he's got e5 so he embraces
the fireworks
in the center that's a game we're going
to keep a very very close
eye on
um we have niels
still in that kind of closed rue lopez
not much has happened there he's gone
queenie too
that's on top right hand side
and uh
in prague's game over on your lower left
still kind of
developing moves a bit of a lull in the
action i would say fiona in the
remaining games
i know i was just i was thinking hard
where did we go to next where did we go
to next
maybe i'll just leave it to you
oh man putting me on the spot well we
just came from york i wouldn't mind
going back to you actually let's go back
to magnus's game i want to figure out if
magnus actually has anything in this
position or is he just sort of you know
has visited fully neutralized magnus's
opening pressure let's have a look um
something tells me the answer is no and
obviously this is
magnus's calling card he takes positions
that look totally innocuous and turns
them into
convincing victories making it look
like he was winning all along
um so we left the doc when magnus
castled we weren't sure is with it uh
going to go d5 immediately you had
talked about
the possibility of knight e7 but with it
goes for for d5 and we see some trades
in the center
and queen d2 is a
vintage magnus move keeping the tension
constantly forcing his opponents to make
difficult decisions
in this case the decision is whether
black should take on c3
and there's an interesting subtlety here
uh bishop takes e6
is from a human perspective this looks
very very good because the knight is
kind of trapped
and in the event of f takes c6 queen
takes you through well this is out of
the question for buck look at these
pawns right
uh but apparently black has this
incredibly strong
response e4
counter attacking white's knight
and well if white plays queen takes c3
then after e takes f3 this pawn
is going to cause a lot of damage to to
white's king side so
uh black is in tremendous shape here and
so for that reason
white should probably take on c3
and in this position then i have another
question earlier we looked at uh when we
looked at this game that
taking on c4 was no good is there any
ever any moment when that changes when
is black could you consider capturing on
c4
you can consider it here because it's
it's no longer likely that white is
going to take with the pawn with the
center being uh more open
taking with the pawn doesn't make as
much sense so here magnus would
definitely take with a queen
but here's what concerns me about
black's position this queen is on a
fantastic square it can can't really be
attacked and knight a5 is a paper tiger
you just move the queen to e4 and apart
from just being well placed the queen
could also support uh the night maneuver
we talked about knight h4 knight f5
is probably going to be white's
follow-up so for example let's say black
plays queen d7 right knight h4
and white continues to accumulate pieces
on the king's side why can double rooks
on the file pressure f7
and this is uncomfortable this is what
magnus does so incredibly well he lulls
his opponent into a false sense that
that he's neutralized whatever uh
you know
opening unpleasantness there was but
that's not the reality i think magnus is
doing a great job here i was just
thinking actually danya that it's funny
it's almost like a match-up team magnus
with magnus and jordan playing white
against team aneesh
and
x with it the two close friends
and it looks like both magnus and jordan
have succeeded with
the white pieces
to first of all surprise their openings
both fitted and anish have been spending
a lot of time but also to get some
to really ask some quite serious
questions already out of the opening
yeah you know if if black doesn't take
on c3 well then the question is what do
you do
um you could play a move like queen d7
but the drawback of this is that white
can
say hey you know you don't want to trade
all right um i'm going to make you
regret it i'm going to get my knight to
c5
and well b6 can be met with d4 striking
at the center
no i i'm actually
of the opinion that
black's position is quite unpleasant
here and i think this is proven by the
fact that it is taking as long as he is
uh not to overstate the case you know i
think black should definitely keep the
balance with very careful play but
black is the one who needs to be very
careful here
uh yeah for for sure for now uh we will
leave with it to it um
let's see anish
should we go
back there gwen and do you want to look
at e5 or
yes
let's do it then
definitely because and jordan is also
responded by castling
and my prediction is that anish is going
to castle
queenside here because if he castles
kingside
what concerns me tremendously is f takes
e5 followed by
an exchange sacrifice on f6
and you know white doesn't even have to
do anything immediate here
white can play a
relatively slow move like queen f3
attacking f6 and if you just again the
point is that black's pieces are all
stuck on the queen side and they might
not be able to return
in time to save the wide open king
this is not an issue style
uh style of position
castling long at least the king is
relatively safe here and if white just
plays f takes e5 and d takes e5
this is very bad because the knight
swings back to d7
and white has created too many holes
in the center so this is out of the
question memories of the goal posts uh
confirmation from an earlier that's
right
yeah and a niche currently contemplating
this position already down to below an
hour on the clock in such a complex
position that is a pretty big concern
i mean i am with you that i don't think
a niche will cancel kingside but is
castling queenside really a move you
want to make or do you just feel that
you have no choice
i think you have no choice and i think i
think he will castle and then i think
jordan's gonna go rook b1 this idea of
chasing the queen away with rook before
and what anish has to decide here is
whether i mean he certainly doesn't want
to play he takes d4 and that just helps
white correct his pawn structure
he takes f4 though is a possibility
you know and then perhaps getting the
rook to e8 in order to pressure
uh the e4 pawn this isn't very
impressive pressure i mean white's that
knight on d2 is such a hero look at how
it's defending
both c4 and e4
white is
in great shape here this is a phenomenal
opening choice by jordan
i mean once again so impressive last
year i think was really the the first
time that
he came to the forefront not just a very
very strong gm but his preparation
uh throughout last year's tata event uh
impressed so much that magnus recruited
him on this team we don't know for sure
of course that that happened after tatar
before but i wouldn't be surprised that
tata had a big role to to play there
and uh jordan this year where he's not
going to defend his title that's for
sure but i think in the dutch clash
especially here with the tournament
being played in the netherlands there's
always a little bit extra at stake
and jordan really really putting anish
to the tasty as you said impressive
preparation and we'll come back here
in a while
for now
um
do we have to to get to the slow
games between frank and fabi maybe we
update there or neil so it's something
happening elsewhere
something is happening a very
interesting move was displayed by sergey
oh
yeah let's go there then
wow and this is a brilliant idea that
he's just come up with i'm pretty sure
over the amazing so he's played c5
now is that a blunders just giving up c5
no well what's the idea of c5 well the
idea is that the knight has lost its
principal defender well why is that
important because now sergey goes queen
e7 and this is just a garden-variety
fork and if white takes on b6 well this
doesn't work out because after f4
the queen takes b2 with check
and after rook f2 even more importantly
queen a3 hitting the bishop and then
black is just going to re
capture b6 with interest this is
not possible shakura has just taken on
c5 i think sergei is going to go queen
e7 so what does dwight do in this
position well white can move the knight
to c6 with tempo
but after queen d7 i think well first of
all there is a potential repetition but
i think what sergey is saying
is that after c takes b6 queen takes c6
white's king the long-term weakness of
white's king actually provides enough
compensation for two extra puns a move
like rook f3
is just terrifying for i mean why could
get checkmated here in two or three
moves so
this i'm really this is happening yeah
queen e7 what a crafty idea this uh c5
move by sergey
yeah and i guess you could also consider
playing f4 but once again that leaves
the bishop on an unassailable square and
it allows black to recover the pawn
i'm expecting
knight c6 and finally queen d4 is an
attempt to defend both pawn and the
knight but it doesn't work bishop takes
c5 distracting the queen
queen takes him and again
uh
the worst thing is that black is also
forking
the b2 pawn
and can we see danya i see that one
person in the chat wrote repetition
incoming what was that line where you
said there is a repetition is that
something that shah
can
bail out with for sure could black uh
deviate
well black can deviate with queen eight
i think this is
uh this is kind of an interesting moment
because queen eight would
i would imagine force white to take on
b6 so the question is how
to what degree does sergey believe in in
this position
or he can play queen d7 this
this gives white the choice of repeating
with knight e5 this is the actual
repetition queen e7 knight c6
uh or chakra could be the one to deviate
uh with c takes b6 if he feels that
black
doesn't have enough compensation now the
engine is still showing
that this could end in some sort of a
weird perpetual their sacrifices galore
on h3 and on e3 so
i'm very curious to see how this is
going to go
well we'll find out after a short break
we'll be back with this game and all the
remaining ones here from round 11 so
don't go anywhere and we'll be right
back
[Music]
welcome again in vikrante shrek stanford
for bending for bending
[Music]
[Music]
lift
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 11 here
at the tata steel chess tournament two
games already done one sadly never
started daniel duboff tested uh positive
to the coronavir to coronavirus so we
wish him a very swift recovery the other
game that ended was a very peaceful
london between duda and shankland dania
yeah well that was a 11 movie game
pretty anti-climactic good prep from sam
and you know impossible to say what was
going through dude's mind maybe just not
not feeling it today whatever it was
that one ends in a draw and by the way
as we take a look at our bird's eye view
over on center top uh toward the right
hand side you can see mamadiarov against
kuryakyn sergey has just played queen d7
so
uh this is
uh very likely to end in the repetition
fiona that we were demonstrating with 95
queen e7
uh really the ball right now is
completely in chakras court he can play
he takes b6
something tells me that he's not going
to do that it just seems a little bit
too scary i mean you could just get you
could get checkmated there
in in three or four moves if you're not
very careful so
but but the funny thing is sergey could
have played queen e8
and and 4c takes v6 so it's this weird
cat and mouse thing where
you know both sides can kind of decide
to play on but it might turn out that
neither side wants it enough
to actually go through with it
sorry danny i'm just reminded so the
other day we all remember the hugely
exciting game between karjakin and
magnus did you see karjakin's tweets
afterwards
oh hashtag like not no 2900 say hashtag
say no to 2900. say no to 2900 well
sergey is underrated he's right he's 27
43 right now he dropped some rating yeah
and he is probably the most solid 27 43
in the history of chess i mean he still
is basically impossible to beat
yeah
so
wow
and well today with the white pieces
shakia he took a very ambitious approach
but the problem with that when you play
a move like g4 later on your king just
find itself in a vulnerable
spot i see danya that the third option
has just popped up here as suggested by
by the computer what is f3
whoa
f3 is a headache inducing move both
bishops are hanging the knight is
hanging
so queen takes c6
first of all you can take on e4 but
after
takes takes takes this is unimpressive
for why due to the weakness of the king
and again rook c1
doesn't work for many i mean you could
always just give a check on d6 so this
isn't with a bishop
uh but the yeah
yeah no i was just gonna say yeah this
doesn't look
too convincing but maybe here yeah
well you can take this bishop but then
black has the inter mezzo bishop c2
queen d2a takes b6 and
yet again guess what happens after ac1
there's a big check on d6 black's bishop
moves away and here black is clearly
better so
i don't feel like there's enough
activation energy for chakriar to
to truly take a big risk here i mean
he's probably happy with this tournament
standing
uh yes he didn't get that full point
against dubov
but i just don't feel like there's
enough here to warrant doing something
too risky yeah now to be honest with
that king on h2 it just
uh looks very very dangerous to play on
and i i wouldn't be surprised if we we
saw a repetition
here
he is thinking this is probably when you
choose an opening like this you're
willing to take some risks this is not
necessarily what you want but very often
that's also how it works out when uh
when your opponent just finds all the
moves and
sometimes there just isn't more than a
draw
yeah i wouldn't be shocked if chakra
plays c takes b6 i mean he's that's
obviously what he's thinking about and
he's genuinely weighing
yeah i mean that look kind of tell
you know says to me that yeah you know
probably not versatile
uh probably you know better to just make
the drug go rest
uh but you never know i mean maybe he'll
have a change of heart it's always fun
to to monitor these types of decisions
you know the anticipation
yeah and for sure well the tournament
situation will be at the back of his
mind
today for the first time is looking and
i don't know i i was gonna say tired who
am i who am i to judge but this is such
a long event and we are
into the the final stretch now and i
think for all the players it's
impossible not to feel to start feeling
the previous 10 rounds
no it's it's very exhausting and and you
know that's part of the reason we like
this tournament it's 13 rounds it really
tests the player's resolve but this is
round 11 and chakra i think he's just
got 95
he has
that doesn't mean he won't um that
doesn't mean he will repeat i mean he'll
have one more chance
to deviate as sergey immediately
responding with b7 let's stick to this
game well in this position chakra has to
go knight c6 i think
yeah so here there isn't and shakir also
has this face a little bit of yes having
resigned himself to
this being the end of the road
my friends and i had an old inside joke
when you'd offer a draw
um
there there's this one motion that
particularly american club players like
to make this motion it's a very
congenial thing that people do and it
means that your opponent's going to take
the drop and the motion is to
sort of bob your head from side to side
i'm doing it on camera
you know and what it means is you know
the position is kind of balanced you
know white's got some advantage so does
black yeah okay draw
and i think they're kind of doing that
thing and i think they're repeating
there we go queen d7
chakra are looking at a score sheet all
of the telltale signs of about of being
about to take the repetition
yeah and for sure very likely i mean uh
i think that's gonna mean the end
uh of his chances or pretty much the end
of his chances to win the tournament
with magnus uh being one of the
remaining two recipients of that free
point from not having watch him
watch him just all of a sudden take on
b6 just saying
that would be that would be amazing but
i i just don't see it happening
both players actually look depressed in
this camera yeah they do
they look incredibly sad
uh but it's that
i feel like you're gonna have to act
disappointed uh for the sake of the fans
like oh man i really don't want to take
the drug even though secretly they'll
come back to the room yes i can watch
the football match now
i can eat early
no i think well on paper i think this of
course with the black pieces uh for
karjakin it's always going to be a a
successful outcome
i think yeah for shahia it's it's
tougher on him because he really needed
that win today with the white pieces to
keep
uh his
hopes alive and as you say well this is
the last moment but i think the knight
has just dropped back to e5 and we'll
see a handshake here now after queen
e7 there it is a smile a handshake a
draw peaceful result and the third game
ending
right after the hour
sergey and mamadiara with the draw in
the early middle game a good attempt by
shakur admirable but sergey he always
seems to be prepared for everything i
mean his ability to find
over-the-board responses is very very
impressive and this move c5 that's
really what did it for him
yeah very impressive uh stuff indeed uh
because for sure he was caught off guard
by jacquez very enterprising
opening play
but yeah that game ended peacefully two
rounds to go for these plays maybe
before we go back to the bird's eye view
we could bring back uh have a quick look
at the standings once again and i'll
just try and make my no
we're not gonna do that
i've been denied dania you've been
denied and we should look at the
sittings instead
no oh my god
no get that out of here okay fine
yeah you've been denied
uh completely denied i mean
frankly i mean why i've what else do you
expect out of our producer you know i
know right
did you expect any a different behavior
fine
okay i think actually the reason i was
denied because they've done great jobs
and already updated understanding so the
results from this round are already
factored in
we see that charging
off he is now on six and a half out of
uh 11 but magnus he has one extra point
still outstanding so daniel if my mouths
don't let me down completely i think for
him
uh for shakir there's no hopes of
overtaking magnus
yeah also nobody got my pun but that's
probably for them
look at the settings here
look at looking at the sittings yeah
well because they're all i got it i just
didn't want to iphone this is
too terrible to acknowledge you didn't
want to i was trying to save you dania
just move on swiftly
all right pretend that never happened
okay i'm strike officially striking it
from the record but yeah i mean magnus
is definitely happy with the result i
mean the more draw is
obviously the better for him and he is
also very heavily rooting for jordan
and we've got two very interesting
developments we have a peace sacrifice
in the grindelways of zepenko game
and we have anish geary castling short
taking a page out of nils's book oh my
goodness
right into the attack which is truly
incredible
um as for which game we look at first i
mean i guess we should look at the
grendelias game let's do it
yeah
but i mean things like we only have four
games left but three of them uh are
heating up
very seriously already
yeah and where did the the peace stack
occurred i will temper you know the
chats excitement of this sacrifice
uh is i wouldn't say it's typical but it
is uh a known idea in this particular
variation of the rue lopez nonetheless
kudos to essay pango knight takes e4
bishop takes c4 and f5 so here's the
point
well the bishop can't drop back to d3
here you just get forked immediately if
you go back to c2
uh black doesn't have to take on d5
immediately black could start by playing
e4
and i mean if you just look at this
position visually look at black's pawns
look at black's piece activity
um and later on the knight could move
away from d5 and the d-pawn could
advance forward the f-bomb could advance
forward this is no fun for white
and both objectively and practically you
can see that the engine doesn't even
think that this is worth going for which
says a lot and it also down here would
almost be some poetic justice for jesse
panko after he suffered that tough
defeat against aneesh where those pawns
just kept storming right down the board
yeah he he wanted some of that as well
now the option
that entices me from nils's perspective
is to play the move c4
and i know this looks ludicrous you're
just leaving the bishop on e4 but the
point is you're transitioning the game
from kind of a tactical battleground
to something more positional currently
black is now up upon
but white's going to recover the e4 pawn
and he's going to get this blockade in
the center so for example bishop f5
knight c3
in fact i'm quite confident that niels
is specifically going to go for for this
line this just seems a lot more fun to
play
than than you know clinging to the piece
and giving black that massive
pawn phalanx in the center
now for sure i mean i would be
absolutely shocked if neil's
uh dropped back to the bishop to c2 that
line we were going down just looked very
very scary
is there anything see if you're not
going to drop the bishop back c4 is the
only move that makes sense i guess
well you could take on f5 but this is
extremely counterproductive after bishop
takes f5 c4 you get a terrible version
of that position in fact white is simply
losing because bishop f6 creates the
unstoppable threat of e4 which is either
going to trap the rook or it's gonna win
the night
uh so if niels is to sack the piece back
the only way to do it is to start with
c4
um
now niels is an incredibly principal
player so he has just done
and it's c4 and it is c
c4
a good move andre is going to take on e4
and the position is going to
quiet down
a little bit i think white is slightly
for choice black is the two bishops and
the f file but white will have this very
powerful e4 square as a base of
operations
for the knights
and we see i guess i panko just sat down
at the board shrugging his shoulders and
look
at at the ceiling which has become so
infamous we're gonna come come back here
c4 seems to be uh
to have been nils's best response
and uh our producer big has prepared a
new little quiz a new little game for us
and the game is whose drink is this but
i'm afraid the black lotus
the black lotus logo appearing in the
background
might have given it away well it's just
the suit yeah you could just uh that's
vin suit
and is that chocolate now i want some
chocolate milk
or some hot chocolate
i think next year we'll have to
i actually just had a hot chocolate
before coming to the playing whole day
do some
very good hot chocolate here oh my gosh
yeah i just had a question for you fiona
is the is the pizzeria still there
parantala is still there it's still
going strong so uh
and it's not i don't think it's going
anywhere it's really one of these
establishment like
one of the legendary places that
everyone associates with vacancy
i love that place and and the best part
is going there that and sun and french
onion soup at the sono bank hotel
um the best part is that french onion
soup is so good when you have a sore
throat which i would get every time i
was in awake and say
um because of the cold but walking into
that pizzeria and
getting like a hot slice of
greasy pizza when it's freezing outside
there's really nothing quite like it and
that place is really famous among all of
the chess players i know magnus is a big
fan of it
uh it's probably the best restaurant of
a gonzay absolutely no for sure a big
favorite with the players and while we
were talking i'm sorry but did you see
the way he visited damned that drink he
did not
take his time to i only enjoy it it's
just no no no he annihilated that hot
chocolate and he probably just got up to
get more oh no he's thinking right now
okay he's gonna quickly make a move so
that he can
shall we update uh his game maybe since
we just came from there
all right fine
he forced me to commentate
okay well magnus has done something
quite interesting now if it had played a
a very natural move queen d6 uh getting
the queen into the action defending e5
and protecting
the bishop and well i pointed out the
idea of going night ago magnus going for
slightly different
okay
he needs to finish this because i don't
know if i can commentate his game maybe
when there's that
the problem is sometimes like i don't
know here in the playing hall if it's
like made with some powder if it was
just pre-prepared sometimes the butter
there are a lot of people who like to do
this don't you think just leave the
smallest amount
well because because
there's a certain uh satisfaction in
knowing that you still have a little bit
left right
you haven't finished it completely you
still have one
lovely you know
a savory drop
left for a you know save for a rainy day
by the way and maybe bigfoot can confirm
but i think this is one of these it's
very typical of the netherlands this
chocolate drink right
sugar milk and it's cold right yeah it's
not an app this one is yeah this isn't
the night so this one i mean i'm not so
such a big fan of this one because it's
cold but i just had my hot chocolate
from zonawank with some whipped cream
that's the real stuff dania
well during the next break i'm
definitely making something i've got
i'm going to dig up some hot chocolate i
also have masala tea
uh which i'm a a huge fan of as well
both tempting options for now shall we
sorry i sidetracked us i feel a little
bit from the game so let's dive back i
don't know
knight d2 so magnus uh
he he takes a different route and and
he's going for a different square and
this this also makes a lot of sense i
mean he wants to go 94 and centralize
the night and you know he's going for
this positional um sort of control over
the center and there's another thing
that vidit has to be very careful about
let's say he plays rook 88 kind of
nonchalantly but what could happen now
after 94 queen e7 which looks fine right
well there's a couple of problems first
of all bishop takes a6 as possible
winning a pawn
uh overloading the b7 second of all
after takes takes white's got knight c5
queen c8 and once again knight takes a6
picks off a free pawn
uh submit it has
this is a threat white is threatening
knight e4
and so the engine proposes the move
bishop d5
uh and even hero i could play knight a4
and in the resulting position i really
like the the placement of the bishop
these doubled pawns may look bad but
they are controlling very important
squares in the center the situation
fiona is still
quite uncomfortable uh for vivid
chocolate milk uh or no chocolate milk
and i mean i was gonna ask you because
we see the engine doesn't seem too
bothered right now it says 0.2 but this
is one of the cases where sometimes i
feel like oh the engine is maybe
exaggerating this doesn't look so bad
but here if i
like i'm a lot more scared for village
shall we say than just a 0.2 position
well the no point too is magnus's
specialty i think if somebody wrote a
book of magnus's best games i mean there
are books of magnus's best games 0.2
would be a good title because that's
what he aims for out of the opening
uh he and and this is you know what i
talked about earlier he's not
always looking to kill his opponent on
move 15. he's looking to cause a little
bit of discomfort
and then nurture
that all throughout the game
but here like to me it feels that it's
already more than a little discomfort
fitted down to 52 minutes and uh yeah
just not clear exactly how
how you meet this what is queen b4
well that's another idea that i had this
forces the queen trade because the queen
can't drop back to b2 you lose the
knight however after takes takes takes
takes
well the question is whose pawn
structure is weaker yeah black has this
pressure on b2
but it's nothing special rook ac1
happens
maybe black can go
knight a2 and then back to b4
actually i don't really see how white
can avoid
the repetition here
i guess rook fc1 is possible and even
though you give up the f file you have
this monster square on e4
i think that it is probably seriously
contemplating this option though it's
tempting to get this into an end game
uh but we all know what happens when you
get a slightly worse end game against
magnus and let me just
give you a hint it's not good
it's not good indeed
and
shall we bring back the bird's eye view
and
uh we should update i'm still curious
about anish just castling into the
apparent
danger shall we start with that or do
you want to go to prague
now let's start with that um the prague
game is very slow moving i mean we're
not really missing much there they're
just sort of still making
uh surface level improvements to their
position now a big moment of truth here
for jordan as he's taken on e5 is he
going to go through
with the exchange sacrifice and this is
you know we always say that it's easy to
sacrifice other people's pieces and
truer words have really never been
spoken
it's hard to find a follow-up here fiona
because okay the check is very tempting
but if you just play very superficially
the queen is going to drop back to c6
and white if white's play evaporates
and it does here because the bishop is
just very lame white could end up just
being an exchange down and losing
so the engine suggests this very
cold-blooded move and it was at one
point suggesting knight f1
okay well that opens up the bishop
the knight is heading to h5 or f5
and you know the queen can swing to g4
at the right moment so something like
this
i would be very very impressed if jordan
you know uh that would be a very gutsy
decision and finally he's got
alternatives
i mean there was also the move i saw
that the engine had briefly flashed it
up after the the exchange sacrifice on
f6 and takes
uh i think queen f3 was another
possibility that flashed up for a second
yeah so that attacks f6 and after queen
c6 this is the most enginey move of all
time if
for
just deploying the bishop to eight i
mean it makes sense right you're getting
the bishop onto an active square it's
just that one of the hardest things to
do is to play
slow moves when you've sacrificed
material to to have that presence of
mind now the point is also if knight
takes c4
that uh does white's bidding for him
bishop c4 bishop c4 you just trade
everything
and then you win the game with the move
bishop h6 creating unstoppable threats
along the dark squares so
again this is a big moment of truth for
jordan he i'm sure he knows that this is
a critical moment and if he doesn't
sacrifice an f6 well he could definitely
play
uh play a move like like rook b1 and you
know still prepare that idea of work
before
what do you think the chances are he
will take on f6
i think the longer he thinks the greater
the greater the chances i think if he
takes another 10 minutes on this
position
i would say the chances are over 50 but
if he makes a move
within the next 10 minutes i would vote
a higher probability that it's going to
be a move like rook b1
very interesting a crucial a quick
critical moment here in that game
between jordan and anish will come back
i i suspect and uh jordan will spend
some more time here to to make up his
mind
and uh that gives us the chance
wow
village with f5
yeah i think that's actually a very good
move it stops i mean it stops knight e4
it's committal yeah i mean you're you're
advancing your pawns and that's over on
your top left uh but
he is stopping the knight from heading
to e4 which is very important i think
that's the correct move actually
very nice and
shall we update prague shall we update
gwendelus against
where do you want to go
prague let's go to prague
um and then we can go to rome and
uh and paris
some nice destinations indeed
no i love frog um
i i've played in the czech republic many
many times i mean they have such a
long-standing uh tradition of this jack
tour which has oh yeah
yeah yes
um okay so let's see uh we haven't
missed so much here at all let's just go
back a few moves i have a funny story
from the czech republic before
we update you know czech of course in
russian are
you know they're both slavic languages
so there's similarities
uh but but they're not even close to
being mutually intelligible so there's
certain words
that are common you know i could read
menus sort of
uh but there's also false cognates you
know there's words that exist in both
languages but mean completely different
when there would be construction
uh there would there would be a sign
with the word uh
and
as far as i know that means attention in
czech but it means shame
in russian so i was like why is it
always a shame when there's road work
going on like
is it really such a shame that they're
improving the rest then of course i
realized
um that's very funny completely
different things
anyways
back to the game
so back to the game in prague um
we left it off the last time when we
thought he might play knight a2 we could
have a potential repetition on the cards
but none of that happened
yeah i mean they're instead kind of
making improvements to their position
rook ad8 rockefty one rook fv8
and prague dropping his bishop back to
b1
uh creating direct contact between his
rook and the pawn of d4 i think he's
sort of implying that you know at one
moment at some point he wants to go e4
and fabiano
dropping the bishop back to d6 so and
and now we have rookie once we have this
kind of weird
kind of slightly weird maneuvering game
prague i definitely think is aiming for
e4 and he is again inviting fabiano to
return to b4 which is not out of the
question because this pins the rook and
we could see this repetition we we
absolutely could
uh can fabi play a move like e5 i i
think the answer is no this would be
premature
uh because after white just trades
everything
you mean you have a classic isolated
queen pawn situation with
a monster blockader on on d4 so
currently the ball is in fabie's court
will he play bishop before
or will he refrain from the repetition
yeah a big decision
for him as i'm reading in the chat that
niels is much better is that correct did
we miss something there i think we
should go back to neil grendell yeah
it does look like andre has
overestimated his queenside play i think
you know i think c4
maybe i don't think he andre missed it i
think he underestimated it and you know
one of the hardest things in chess is
switching
uh psychologically from a situation
where you're prepared to develop the
initiative you've stacked the piece
you're excited all of a sudden you know
all of a sudden the position is has
quieted down and you have to be very
careful it appeared that the correct
idea here was to go bishop e8 and to
swing this bishop around to
g6 but instead andre going for a very
concrete approach he takes on c4 and he
goes knight a4
and rook b8 but neil's very calmly
developing his final piece
and
you know the problem for andre is that
if he he goes rook b2
i think there's a very specific idea
on the king side which is to play f4
and tear everything open
and it's kind of a similar problem to
what gary is facing you've got these
pieces that are suspended on the queen
side and if you actually look at the
center and the king side that bishop is
vulnerable the pawn on d6 is a weakness
white's position has tremendous
potential
and andre has to be very very careful in
this position i think he's worse
um the eval bar is giving 1.5
that is maybe a slight overestimation
but no question that white is
significantly better here
yeah i mean it's strange rook b2 looks
like a move uh that looks so natural you
can get your your work into the enemy uh
position what are the other options here
for for black
well i can play bishop f5 that's kind of
a typical move but once again i think f4
looks like a very very strong move
um okay the eval bar is kind of going
back and forth it's not obligatory
but i i feel like it's the principled
approach you're opening up the center
uh with white's pieces better equipped
to handle that he takes f4 bishop takes
e4 f4 i mean black had abandoned
entirely the idea of getting the rook to
b2
but again look at this position pawn on
d6 is weak
white's piece is perfectly placed in the
center bishop on e7 is lame and at night
on a4 as well
yeah what exactly is it doing i mean
it's not going to c3
um and even if it drops back to b6 where
is it going from there so there's just
the sense that black's pieces are quite
discombobulated
uh and this is right up nielsen's alley
he loves these complex
semi-tactical positions and i think the
last game fiona wasn't necessarily
smooth
but i think i can sense that it's given
him a lot of confidence i saw that world
chess actually yesterday
made a facebook post saying
niels grandilius had one million ways to
win but didn't
and then they said that later on
uh
that daniel started playing for a win
which is not exactly correct i mean
there was no point at which daniel which
uh i showed this to niels and he told me
there is a reason i refrain from social
media niels is very principled on this
he doesn't check any social media
while he's playing the tournaments and
when i showed him this he was like yeah
i'm very
very clever not to be looking at social
media while i'm playing yeah there was a
lot of monday morning quarterbacking on
facebook and yes it was a very sloppy
end game no question about it but niels
suffered through three time pressure
phases
and uh i feel like he was the deserving
winner i mean i think his biggest chance
was probably to win that game in the
middle game yeah uh but you also have to
take your hat off to him and he kept his
foot on the gas pedal in the purest
sense of the word he just never let up
and uh yeah that's how you win games we
see andre uh does indeed go bishop f5
and i think really a big moment here is
niels going to decide on f4 i feel like
this is such a move in his style i think
he's going to play
yeah i've i think f4
is surely the move that he's been
thinking about for a couple of moves as
we see him return to the board and this
is looking very promising for nilsa
we'll come back there and let's go now
to pragnanda and karana
yeah well uh karwan is still thinking
after rookie one both of them now below
an hour on the clock
and you can just sense what fabi is
thinking about well i could play b4
well i you know i could play bishop
before but
yeah i mean i i really didn't want to to
repeat repeat moves
but but then i realized that uh today i
really don't have much of a choice and
uh
i just wanted to play a solid game today
uh but
i just don't see what i mean there's
also the move c5 here i was going to
slide out the question yeah about this
once again i think such a fascinating
topic is pawn breaks in the center
when do you unders where are they good
what is c5 here e5 you already said
earlier you think uh it doesn't quite
work for yeah so what about c5
well the problem is there's a lack of
equivalency
in the accessibility of these two weak
squares right both players have a weak
weakness on b5 or b4 but white can
access it black can't
and that's what i think really
discourages black from playing c5 it's
not the end of the world
but you know the other knight could come
out to e5
and uh you know this could get very
unpleasant if you just look at this
position black is extremely cramped uh
this knight is totally unassailable
and it could even move on to to d6 under
a different set of circumstances so
uh fabi is not one to burn all of his
bridges just to avoid a draw he plays
the position and that's what makes him
great and that's what makes his career
that's what makes him so incredibly
stable
right he he doesn't tilt
uh by by making unobjective
decisions so i think there's a high
probability he goes bishop b4 i was just
going to say that the more we look at
this position the more
you convince me that the other
moves are not that great i also think
there is a big chance far be about to
make a move and bishop before dania you
called it
yeah but the thing is after i think
prague is going to repeat
but after rookie d1
uh which i believe
yeah
okay there came from there was just
making sure it didn't come from f1
uh i don't see
any uh enticing alternatives for prague
because now of course he is pinned so
the movie four doesn't make much sense
here i mean black takes on e4 and you
can't take back with a knight and
obviously you don't want to give away
your light scored bishop
but for fabi
he can refrain from the repetition after
rookie d1 but once again fiona i just
don't see
how black can improve his position and
just making a random move and getting a
worse position is not up fabi's alley so
now the ball in prague's court but i'm
anticipating rookie d1 i think there's a
high probability of this game into the
draw i agree with you i also think it
could be a little while as both players
might be investing some time before
they repeat if they repeat
so
we're going to bring back the the bird's
eye view for a second
and
see
shall we update maybe we can update
magnus's game and then we'll go on a
quick break what do you think
sounds like a plan
so magnus he is taking his first
really big think of the game
as vinit deciding on the move f5 it is
committal
you know these pawns could potentially
end up a little bit vulnerable and to
that end i think the under the move rook
f2
comes to mind you want to double on the
f5 and you want to target
the f5 pawn
now a move like g6 is possible but it's
really really weakening
and white could still proceed with rook
af1 you could think about g4 e4
these moves become possible so this is a
move right up magnus's alley i'm
anticipating rook f2
if i had to predict i would say he's
going to play rf2
rook f2
and one of the questions the knight from
d2 are you happy with how that's
positioned right now keeping all the
options open what do you envision for
this night in the future
keeping the options open is a good way
to characterize it well currently it's
fulfilling the important role of uh
reinforcing the bishop
so after bishop takes c4
white will take back probably with the
knight although you you could take back
with a queen with check also so
for now the knight is sort of kept in
reserve it could later go back through
f3 to h4
but magnus likes to keep his options
open he likes to keep things flexible
and for now i think the highest priority
is to figure out a way
to to pressure these pawns on f5 and e5
so you're expecting rook f2 magnus
doesn't look like he is ready to make a
move yet so we are gonna come back to
this one after a short break don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're the van forest will he defend his
current title unfortunately i think uh
that
uh
chance has passed but he's certainly
looking to get a win here against his
compatriot anishiri dania
yeah you can see it's in his eyes he's
got that he's got that look he's got the
fighter look
uh but um he has not i'm sorry to say
taken on f6 he has gone for the more
peaceful alternative rook b1
i see that
a lot of fans in the chat even on
twitter i saw are disappointed they were
hoping to see a rook f6 appear on the
board but even after rook b1 uh jordan
seems to still be doing quite well here
yeah he's in good shape and again it's
easy to sacrifice other people's pieces
and
when you see that the eval bar is in
white's favor after rook takes subjects
it's so easy to just say oh obviously
the sacrifice is good
remember that jordan doesn't know you
know what the evaluation is so it's a
lot harder to evaluate a sacrifice like
this when you don't have any information
beforehand i mean i talked about this
many times so
i felt like he would take on f6 but
rookie one is a very understandable
decision now again anish has to decide
you know what is his priority going to
be here now he can move the knight away
from f6
but the problem is that that doesn't get
rid of the long-term uh problems with
this kingside and jordan could lift his
rook up to h3
another possibility is to play rook a to
e8 this is i think
maybe the likeliest move
at least this is the most natural move
there is still a sacrifice on f6
possible but my guess is that jordan i
mean he wants to play rook before but
that could end up being premature fiona
could end up helping black
to get his pieces back to toward the
king side which uh anish wants to do
anyway and this also hits d4 so
i don't know i think rook b1 is just
sort of a flexible semi-weighting move
but it's also an interesting spot that
jordan puts a niche in because of course
both players i'm sure
at the previous turn saw the possibility
of work takes
f6 but if you're black
you see okay my opponent hasn't gone for
it once but if i allow the opportunity
at the next turn again he might just do
it i have to still evaluate
um
how do i feel it could do you think it
could even be that anish changed his
mind while jordan was thinking and
thinking maybe i shouldn't have allowed
rook takes f6 and now things
better do something about it
yeah but now it's this cat and mouse
game right okay so you see if he didn't
take once is he gonna take now
and these psychological considerations
come into play but look at the clock i
mean jordan also
has has taken a lot of time but a niche
now down to 44 minutes this is a time
scramble in the making where only 15
moves into the game and
uh we haven't even reached uh the most
complex position i i anticipate that
this middle game is going to continue
being
as as full of nuance and danger for
black as it has been
so far
for sure we'll leave a niche to it and
some great news if we bring back the
bird's eye view just as we were coming
back from the break we saw that fabiano
has decided not to go for the repetition
so great news that game continues
indeed he says nope we're not making a
draw we're not going home just yet he
plays rook d8 to see it and done yet
which is experience yeah just before we
dive in there i see that the queens have
come off and the magnus vetted clash on
the top
left magnus with a very interesting idea
he goes for the end game and he doesn't
take on c4 with an idea recaptures with
the b-pawn
uh opening up the b-file he wants to put
a rook on b1 and despite his pawn
structure appearing very damaged uh
these are the kinds of end games i think
where magnus excels the most he doesn't
really care what the objective
evaluation is we'll definitely take a
very very deep dive
into that end game um
in just just a few moments shall we
start with a frog game by the way niels
has played up four
i'm not not too surprised niels who's
had such a tough side to his tournament
and won an epic game against the dubai
two days ago today he seems to be
pressing against jesse panko just as we
tune in prague is making his next move
but let's go back so we saw this moment
where we thought fabiano uh and prague
could repeat with this uh
bishop b for bishop d6
dance but then fabi the one to deviate
here
abby deviates with a move that you know
you might be wondering what the idea is
and it might be that there's no specific
idea i mean maybe fabio is eyeing the
move c5 after all
uh but it's more that he's tossing the
ball back into white's cord and saying
all right prague well
uh you know find a move and
this is what these types of positions
often are all about i was expecting
prague to make a slow improving move
like h3 but he has decided to go for a
very concrete approach knight e5
offering a trade of knights and if black
takes it and goes knight t7
uh you're gonna get this structure where
white's probably going to play f4 black
is quite cramped
uh but of course this is a very
committal approach for white as well i
mean this doesn't this comes with its
associated risks somehow i don't think
that fabia's going to take the knight
though although if you don't take the
knight then i can support it with f4
yeah i was just gonna say also if you
don't take i'm still struggling with the
black position
uh where the pieces are a bit crammed in
by their own uh pawns and i'm
i'm never sure how do i proceed as black
because the only way to liberate myself
is a pawn push but i guess the pawn push
is all still not particularly
appealing
c5 an option here
it definitely is but again white can
stick a knight on b5
and and look at how these knights are so
nicely protected by
by the pawns no and then oh there's
another idea after rookie d8 white has
the move knight a7
if the rook moves to c8 there's the fork
in the frog c7 at the very least white
has a draw by repetition
uh but white in this kind of position
can continue improving i mean even a
move like h3
uh makes it practically difficult for
black to
uh to find a way to disentangle so
yeah no now that we're looking at this
i'm i'm beginning to think it's more
likely that i'm changing my mind i think
perhaps ivy will take on e5 after all
for some time
do you want to have it what did you say
sorry i i didn't mean to for some reason
i feel like fabi there's a non-zero
chance that he grows uncomfortable with
his position and offers a draw which i
was thinking that is what
it's it's possible um and and he might
say you know i should have repeated
moves and from prague's perspective the
repetition could have just happened so
there's a high probability that he
accepts the draw
yeah well we'll see what he comes up
with uh but a an interesting spot here
and let's go to the the magnus ending
against against vidit
yeah and the first thing i would say is
this yes the eval is 0.00 but does that
mean it's a dead draw absolutely not
this is an end game that is full of life
and if every 0.0 game
uh
that magnus had ended in a draw well
then he wouldn't be world champion it's
as simple as that this is one of his
perhaps his greatest uh strength is to
outplay
uh super grandmaster opponents in equal
end games um and a book i was i was
going to say books can be written about
it a book has been written about
magnus's endgames an excellent excellent
book that analyzes
his wizardry and these types of
positions now let's try to understand
what each side's plan
plans are well white's plan is very
straightforward white wants to go rook
b1 let's make a random move for black
let's say g6
now which probably is not such a bad
move
first white can play the move a5 to
clamp down on the b-pawn
well and then white just wants to build
up you know the pressure
on on black's queen side so for that
reason the engine is recommending a very
concrete approach black can try to beat
white to the punch night before
hitting the pawn on c2
and if you go
no not rook fd1 if you go rook fc1
then there's this amazing move e4
okay well what's the idea doesn't that
blunder a pawn well not really because
after de4 rook 88 the knight has to move
aside and look at how terrible white's
pawn structure is going to be as a
result of that
well you could play the move d4 here
fiona but now black
secures the knight with a5 and this is
the secondary point of e4 if flight ever
goes c3 you go from the frying pan into
the fire that knight is even stronger
than it was on v4 and black can solidify
his pawn structure by playing b6 well
did it play knight before
it's entirely possible and he's doing a
good job taking his time in a very
important position i mean if knight b4
is important it shows you just how
misleading the zero zero evaluation also
is because
a knight before is a highly like a very
concrete and quite unusual move like
usually you'd be thinking okay how do i
maybe activate my rooks uh
use the open files maybe do something
with the fonts knight b5 doesn't
immediately
spring to mind but that's the kind of
defense and the kind of moves you need
to find if you want to keep this
position as zero zero against magnus
yeah and my coach would always tell me
that um you know there's there's a
certain way that these games often tend
to go and and the fact of the matter is
that you have to exploit your very first
chance this is the easiest that it's
ever going to be forbidden and my guess
is that if he doesn't play knight before
you know every subsequent uh path to
equality is going to be harder
and harder so i think he senses it
and uh vidit is you know he's so good at
at sensing critical moments and
capitalizing on them i think there's a
high chance that he goes for night
before and fiona um i'll i'll leave you
behind the wheel for just about 45
seconds if you don't mind i did end up
making some masala tea so i have to go
down and
absolutely
i think we're gonna go to the bird's eye
view and i'm gonna have a quick
uh look i'll be right back sure no
worries at all so we see
magnus carlsen there we've just came
from there with vetted uh deep in the
tank is he going to play
night before we will find out and then
next to that second game from the top
left anish giri he is still thinking
after jordan played not rook takes f6 i
think the exchange sacrifice we all were
hoping to see
but rook b1
the threat of rook takes f6 is still
alive izani is going to do something
about that isn't he going to allow you
then another chance to possibly
get that shot in we
will find out
uh we also we had some exchanges i think
when danya comes back we'll dive back in
to pragnanda against fabiano but also
into uh niels grandelius against the
sepango at the top right corner there
the last time we had a look at that
danielle was suggesting f4 for nils
which is what he has
gone for and the the character of that
position has changed quite a bit so i
think um i am going to bring up the game
between
nils and jesse panko
and we will jump back there as we see
the chair the famous stream chair
the the chair life so let's go back um
we left
this off here after bishop f5 and dania
was recommending for nils
to play this move
for opening up the position which is
what nils went for and after e takes f
four
and i'll actually i'll i'll probably
uh wait here for dania because there is
a plethora of choices here for white how
to recapture uh maybe very quickly while
we wait just look at the results under
the player's camera because three games
have already ended in this round 11. we
had two quick draws one between duda and
shankland i'm not sure what happened
there uh would
do that very unusual for him to see her
uh same offer such a quick draw an
interesting tussle between ramirez and
karyakin which ended up ending uh in the
draw as well though and of course the
sad news of the day duboff
testing positive so he is out of the
tournament but danya i brought us here
and i was saying that i was waiting for
you to come back to talk us through the
different different uh options that
niels had he took with the rook but how
do you decide with which piece to take
i don't love that move i felt like
bishop takes up four is more natural
from the perspective
putting pressure on on the d6 pawn but i
think what might have deterred niels
from
taking with the bishop is that rook
bea does create an x-ray against the
queen and it's not so easy to find a
good home for white's queen you know if
it moves to the f file it walks from one
x-ray
to another but the reality is that if
white just goes through ke1 here
this knight on e4 is perfectly well
protected it's not like black can do
anything on the e file so i was fully
expecting niels to take with the bishop
but he's taken with a rook
and he's taking a different approach and
the approach that he's taking i think is
to rapidly
double on the f file and a very helpful
question to ask here
to
enrich our understanding of the position
is who benefits in the event that all of
the rooks are traded that all four works
are traded
and i think the answer to that is white
and i think that's why niels is has
chosen this so let's imagine
that we have a trade of of rooks i think
the reality now is that black is the
only one with a serious weakness and
white can pile up on that weakness with
bishop f4 and then trying to get the
queen to g3
this is kind of a risk-free
position where where white is playing
for two results so i can understand why
niels did this but something about this
just seems a little bit awkward to me
the bishop on e3
isn't too thrilled uh with this with
that rook on f4
and once again actually dania can we go
back to jordan against anish because i
see that some of our team behind uh
behind the scenes have been spending a
little bit of time looking at the rook
sacrifice so if we go back instead of
rook b1 and um
i'm going to try and read out the lines
so there is something apparently after
brook takes takes
and queen f2
which we didn't really
look at apparently there was a crazy
line which goes quindy one check
knight f1
queen takes d3
and queen h
now is the computer catching up it was
giving minus five initially oh my
goodness that's a crazy line
and the reason this is so good i think
is that white is threatening
bishop h6 with uh impending checkmate on
the dark squares and somehow this queen
is completely limited it can't go back
to e4 it can't join the defense
so that means that that changes so maybe
what we are saying if i'm not missing is
that truck f6 maybe was even stronger
than we thought
yeah i mean this is insane but that is
an impossible impossible knight f1 in
this position how do you not play bishop
f1 you have to figure out that you can
simply give up the bishop and and then
play the incredibly cold-blooded queen
h4 that is that is an amazing line
uh
worst one one can't expect jordan to
to go for this
uh but nonetheless good good analysis
that was fun yeah for sure shout out to
our team behind the scenes and water
line indeed and instead in the game
while jordan didn't take he went rook b1
and uh anish has just played c5 a very
committed pawn push
committal indeed and he's trying to get
jordan to go d5 when i think
uh that knight well i guess knight b7
allows the sacrifice but probably 98 is
more accurate the knight heads for d6
this is of course
a very typical idea jordan is not gonna
go d5 that locks up the center uh it
kills white's attack instantaneously
uh what will jordan do well you know
what fiona once again you can very
uh he very well might sacrifice and the
computer definitely likes this and once
again suggests the move knight to f1 as
i previously explained it's the same
idea you want to go queen f2 you want to
go bishop h6
and there isn't a huge hurry white has
kind of a long-term attack on the king
side as well as short-term threats of uh
checkmate on f6
and g7 this is really the moment of
truth do you think that the inclusion of
the pair of moves rook b1 and c5
makes it more enticing to take on f6
less so it doesn't really change
that's a great question well
i don't think it changes the situation
too much after rook takes f6 the
question is
i don't see an altar there he goes sorry
daniel rook f6 has just been played wow
it has and what i'm most curious about
us how jordan is going to follow this up
this is what i'm really really
interested in
will he play that f1 or
is he going to go for wait can white
still go for queen f2 i always wonder i
was that was gonna be my next question
and queen d1
let's see but now the rook is hanging on
b1 oh
that's all that but wait a second
there's still queen is four still
possible
and even after two years meeting with
bill paige takes two rooks down
what an unbelievable unbelievable
position white is winning and the eval
bar it took a second but now
it says it's equal
and it says that bishop b7
is the move here
and the point is that bishop h6 can be
met with queen takes e4
but that's not the end white goes d5
black goes h5
okay i'm done this is ridiculous
this is ridiculous what a crazy
wait is h5 dmd movie
i think it is well the h5 is actually
very logical because after bishop h6
you've opened yourself a a nice little
retreat square on h7
and well this is a draw rook bishop ffa
f8 well probably not rook cafe queen b1
is
queen b1 is more precise now look at
this queen f6 rook takes f8 and just a
normal garden variety perpetual with
green f5 check
unbelievable
these lines are so nuts and i'm not
surprised to see the jacket come off
here for jordan
well we know what that means that means
he smells blood
but he's got 48 minutes
and my guess is that he's going to take
probably 15 of them at least
uh to find
the the proper follow-up we'll see
crazy
crazy moment here uh with jordan he
didn't take on f6 the first time around
now he has
a knight f1 probably a more natural i
mean
if jordan plays queen f2 that would be
absolutely incredible no
i would be tremendously impressed if
indeed he
he figures this out that would be a
sight to behold
we will leave jordan to it but we'll
come back here very soon for sure uh
such an exciting game between the two
dutchies and alice uh where
i see that village hasn't gone knight b4
instead going e4 which changes the
character of the position again a bit
dania do you want to update us there
yeah i mean we talked about that idea i
mean we were proposing night before
rook c1 and now e4
bit it going e4 straight away now
d-take c4 has to be evaluated and my
guess is that he still wants to go rook
88 or fd8
and ultimately
you know white could end up with an
extra pawn but i'm having a very very
hard time believing
that white has any serious chances with
this kind i mean this pawn structure is
too ugly uh to afford syria chances
rookie 8 knight c5 knight a5
is the computer line hitting defending
b7 and hitting c4 this
probably will fizzle out into a draw and
if magnus doesn't take on e4
well d4 transposes into a line where
honestly i think only black can be
better so
i think magnus
i mean this is the big decision does he
play d4 and potentially risk
being worse or
does he take on e4
where the likeliest outcome is
uh simplification and and a draw
interesting moment here for max yeah i
think magnus for a second had a little
bit this face you know when he's
not happy
that he has a feeling his opponent has
found a way to neutralize
um
to neutralize
any any kind of problems but will which
do you think of the approaches uh do you
think magnus is going to go for
there's a third move by the way there's
rook a to b one here covering the before
square
and attacking b7 and what could happen
here there could be a trade on d3
followed by b6 and you know
the issue is that it looks like uh
white's pawn structure has been
corrected but that's actually deceptive
because if you look at the pawns this
one can be very easily targeted with
several moves as is this one i mean
black can go rook fv8 and hit that pawn
as well whereas white has not succeeded
in going a5 and freezing black's queen
side so
this doesn't seem too enticing for me
either i mean it's equal i don't think
white is worse here but
and i have to say kudos to to vidic too
i think uh after magnus sprung that
little opening
uh surprise then it kind of went back
into an italian but uh not the kind of
joke of piano we usually see and i think
venit has handled all of that um very
well
yeah and i think if the game does end in
a draw which is the likeliest outcome at
this point i think all the backseat
drivers on on social media are going to
be criticizing magnus for
uh for going into an end game this
quickly and it's entirely possible that
magnus kind of thought of it
schematically he thought okay i'm going
to pressure b7 and didn't really stop to
consider
concrete candidate moves
um i i think that rook f2 you know vidit
was uncomfortable
and i think magnus will be kicking
himself potentially
for for not keeping the tension but
we'll see i mean there's plenty of life
left in this end game and the game is is
obviously not over
for sure for now let's bring back der
bird's eye view as magnus ponders his
uh next move and dania where would you
like to go back to jordan has gone queen
f3 and anish responded with queen c6
so let's take a deep dive there that's
really
uh heating up now so
queen f3 a move we had seen earlier in
the first version of the the exchange
sack um
here also queen f3 of course what does
it do it hits the pawn on f6
anish responded with queen c60 do you
have any options if we go back alpha
move
no i don't think so because you can't
afford to give up f6
so queen c6 the only move and now the
question what's next
well my guess is he's gonna go d5 queen
d6 and now knight f1 and again all the
pieces come alive we've already talked
about this idea
now black cannot afford to waste time
taking pawns because here there's
actually the move knight e3 immediately
bishop takes d3 knight f5 with mate i
mean or you win the queen
so in fact it's crucial for black to
keep this bishop on a6 so that it can
move back to c8
uh you if the knight lands on f5 the
game is over so you need to be able to
play bishop c8 and you should probably
go king h8 here
uh knight g3 bishop c8 but the knight
doesn't have to go to f5 it can also go
to h5
man i i would feel so uncomfortable here
if i'm a niche
i maybe he's okay here
but it just feels it feels like this is
just not his type of position yeah
definitely i mean this looks
horrible and then all of the whole line
was more or less forced if jordan goes
uh d5 and and knight f1
it doesn't look like anish can improve
anything at any turn here
and what makes matters worse is that
again white is not in a big hurry it's
not like if white doesn't do something
in the next two moves black is all of a
sudden going to consolidate black isn't
even close to consolidating it's not an
a5 totally out of commission and white
can slowly accumulate by developing the
bishop going over kf1
and then at his leisure taking that pawn
on f6 this is
very very uh
this is bad i think this is outright bad
for anish yeah and i see a few comments
in the chat saying i don't understand
why aneesh castled king side rather than
queenside and danya i mean you pointed
that out out at the time and i think
that's exactly where anish's uh trouble
started
well i think he was already quite
uncomfortable and
i think it's very easy to to
retrospectively say well this was a
terrible decision but again evaluating
this rook sacrifice uh this exchange
sacrifice accurately is actually quite
difficult so
i think anish kind of took a page out of
nielsen's book and did something
provocative in the hopes that it would
throw jordan off and in the hopes that
jordan wouldn't you know wouldn't
ultimately decide on the sacrifice
because if white doesn't take on f6 then
black is totally fine so it was a
provocative decision it's understandable
and the game is very far from being over
so by the way let's wait
for immediately
knight f1 immediately so or no he went
e5 sorry he did go d5 yeah that's also
not what i saw it's going down the line
that we were just looking at
uh anish is already
i thought he was getting ready to make a
move king h8 really looks natural to get
that out of trouble
that's what either that or bishop c8 but
i think he's going to go king [ __ ] i'm
99 sure he's going to go king h8 here
yeah and there he goes king h8
is on the board
jordan i think knight g3
is just a natural move to continue it
and
this looks so so scary for a niche
yeah but it would be sloppy to play
knight e3 because after bishop c8 you
don't have any more pathways for the
knight
so it's very important to actually go to
g3 rather than e3 so you have
uh the potential to go to h5 i think
we're going to see that
from jordan
for sure and well maybe while we leave
here into it i think knight g3 will
probably be played
quite quickly uh maybe we can
go
go check in maybe with gwen dalio cse
panko what do you think dania
yeah let's do that and then let's go to
the marijuana game
okay so andre doing i think a really
good job here of of stabilizing the
situation he's gotten his rook from the
b file to the e file where it's
you know getting more bang for its buck
it is still x-raying the queen
and my question here is how niels
improves his position i i mean he's got
everything on nice squares but again
this bishop on e3
is is a little bit uncomfortable i guess
it's the only piece that's not
uh ideally located and
it's hard to get this bishop active as
long as the rook
remains on f4 i'm not really seeing it
fiona i'm not seeing
uh how niels puts more pressure at least
at least superficially
it's such a strange position because it
looks
nice
and then you get to that next stage of
exactly the nitty-gritty of well what do
i actually do
yeah i mean there's h4 that's an
interesting idea
the point is that
knight p6 knight g3 you attacked the
bishop and then once the bishop moves
back well here comes the h-pawn
uh sending the bishop further back
but
okay but in response to h4 i don't
really see why
oh h6 apparently the engine
suggests queen h5 oh oh the point is
that there's no g6 square for the bishop
anymore that's that's very important
because the queen h5 here
would would run into the simple bishop
g6 or
here rather so h4 very very interesting
idea but
i don't know how human that is
i mean it looks
it looks it doesn't look like the kind
of move you want to make in this
position you feel like okay my problem
piece is the bishop on e3 how do i
improve that how do i untangle
and so
for h4 to even appear on your your radar
would be quite impressive
indeed
yeah h4 uh
no sorry go ahead
no i i agree i think this is the kind of
move that when it's made on the board it
looks
it's like okay you can kind of
understand it
but man oh man it's not easy to not easy
to decide on something like this
yeah and niels
if you wanted i think h4 is really not a
human move
how do you get that bishop out of that
how do you want how what attempts do you
have to untangle let's say
well you can go bishop f2 but that move
fails in this position on account of
bishop g5 and there's that queen again
right that queen causing problems for
white
uh so that leads to the idea well maybe
you can move your queen well where can
you move it like you go queen f2
but well now that creates more problems
now if you take on f8 black recaptures
with tempo
and i really feel like niels has
squandered a lot of his advantage if not
all of it by taking on f4 with the rook
yeah i'm not so also surprised because
it was a decision that seemed to be made
quite fast we saw the position after f4
and suddenly rook f4 was already on the
board so it doesn't spend
too much time there but
and now maybe paying the price for that
quick
decision we will come back here as well
as i was saying reading in the chat that
fabiano might be making
some
progress so maybe we can check in there
yeah it looks like fabi has found a a
very very nice setup
and if anything his position might be
for choice now so what happened well
d
e5 knight d7 prague building
the battery and threatening checkmate
but this knight on fate is such a nice
piece it's very hard to get to
and it obviously prevents queen h7
prague going knight
e2 and my guess is that he he's swinging
the knight maybe around to h5 but but if
i be immediately taking this opportunity
to start expanding on the queen side and
putting pressure b5 i love that move
and the point is that if if prague
continues his night maneuver i think
fabia's going to trade on a on a4
and then he's going to redeploy the
bishop to a6
high perfume ketoing
and pressuring c4 but prague is the very
interesting idea of going rook d4 saying
hey take my pawn i don't care i'm going
for checkmate look at how many pieces
white has aiming at the king so
this is a very double-edged idea
uh by fabian even here rook d4
i mean the engine doesn't recommend it
but
i would be
certainly
considering and trying to evaluate that
but kudos to fabi he
makes a gutsy call not going for the
repetition and now
you know choosing a position that could
end up being very dangerous indeed and i
mean for prague maybe he also is happy i
think it is his first classical game
against uh fabiano of course a quick
draw would have been a good result but
the fact that he gets to battle it out
he has
uh the bishop and the queen looking
right down at black's king
and uh this position although the engine
boy says oh i prefer black um black
might have to fend off some uh some
attack in the near future so exciting
game on the horizon here as well
we'll bring back the bird eye view and
danny i'll let you choose one final game
before we go on a quick break well
jordan went 93 he didn't go knight g3
that is
wow let's let's go to that game for a
second i'm not understanding
why he went 93 now i will add a
disclaimer i still think that he's got a
great position
i mean anish goes bishop c8 and jordan
could just play bishop d2
and i guess what he wants to say is that
he wants to get this bishop around to h4
and then the rook to f1 and he's trying
to keep his knight as centralized as
possible where it reinforces the c4 pawn
so i understand his logic
i just felt like knight g3 knight h5
looked so overwhelming
that it's hard to understand
uh why jordan refrained from it but he's
still very much in the driver's seat
yeah i'm also uh very much surprised
bishop c8 of course you were saying
earlier the only move to stop the knight
from
landing
on f5
and well we'll come we'll come back to
this one four very very uh interesting
games still going we're gonna have a
quick break and uh we'll be right back
here with the action from round 11.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2010 when i played in the c group it was
uh fantastic i mean that was really the
first time for me that i played
you know on the same stage let's say as
all the top players and i had them so
close up and i could just go there and
watch their games and so on and for a
young boy of course it was fantastic
i do like to sit down with an actual
chessboard and analyze things and or at
least think about things but when i use
let's say technology or engines i try to
use the best ones
always
i think the next development we will see
this is a bit of a guess but i think
what they will try to do is because now
they are they are so incredibly strong
and so much stronger than all the humans
but rather what they will be
improving is uh to make them play more
like a human or make them play more
similar to how the best humans play
so i think we will have a
shift to the engines working in that
direction rather than just pure you know
strength improving
this year of course and last year was a
little bit
strange because of the pandemic
we don't have this vibe in in the
village of the
let's say
the festival i think we still managed to
keep some of that spirit alive and but
of course we are hoping for
you know back to
to the old way soon
russian is not the only one hoping that
we'll be back to the good old days soon
as we just saw him make a move uh in the
the position danya let's jump back in
there
do it okay so
niels did end up going queen f3 escaping
the e file and moving on to the f file
andre immediately responding bishop g6 i
mean the bishop was attacked
and neil's repositioning his queen to g3
so he spent a couple of tempe
trying to find the best square that he
can for his queen which i think is very
logical
um and
the other thing that the queen
accomplishes there is that it obviously
pressures d6
but there is this very interesting try
for black knight b2 i mean if you're
going to
keep your knight on the rim or on the
queen side you might as well squeeze
something out of it and from b2 it
applies very serious pressure
on the the c4 pawn and you can imagine
that this knight on d2 is quite
overextended it's now charged with uh
defending essentially the two most
important
uh points in the position the knight on
e4 and the pawn on c4 so
uh definitely i think nielsen's
advantage has evaporated the position
remains incredibly complex all three
results are possible
and a big moment here for andre
uh who i think senses that neil is niels
is slipping a little bit
um and neil neil grindelius
but how exactly does he
proceed well knight b2 is an option
knight b6 is a similar idea just going
from the other side that's also an
option
we'll see
what about trading works uh started
trading initiating some trades on the f5
would that favor white because now this
bishop
finally
it would definitely favor white largely
because yeah the pawn 96 is now simply
attacked you have to play this very
awkward rook v8
well and now white can continue
king side shenanigans knight 596.
that's really what the battle is
revolving around can white tie black
down to the d6 pawn or can andre
uh keep his pieces as active as possible
and and prevent white uh from focusing
his energies on that pawn
yeah so rook f
for will definitely not be played and i
think it does make sense whether it's
going to be knight b6 or or knight b2 we
will find out but
it seems like that's the only piece
really right now in black's position
that doesn't really do anything at all
yeah and that's why i think andrei's
very likely to take one of those
nice a great move and played executed
quickly i mean he just senses that this
is the moment where he can try to
overtake the initiative and i think nils
uh very likely just underestimated this
move or simply outright missed it you
might have forgotten that his pawn on c4
is a serious target it's it's isolated
it's
it's backward and yeah the knight on d2
uh is not the the most solid foundation
you know on which to build a house
yeah and it's strange you also somehow
cannot really easily dislodge that night
um
from from being inside here deep inside
your own camp
yeah i mean if you try to go rook b1 i
mean it's very clear that this move
comes with tremendous problems and i
think black can even get away with
knight takes c4
knight takes c4 now a very interesting
line rook takes f4 queen takes f4 looks
like black has lost a piece right no
rook f8 now uh where is the screen going
absolutely nowhere it cannot keep
contact
uh with the knight and oh whoops i
didn't mean a fast word and one more
thing in this line
rick b1 knight takes c4 knight takes c4
rook takes f4 white has to take on f4
with the bishop
and after bishop takes e4 white has to
play rookie one
the point being if bishop takes d5 then
there's knight b6
okay well this is this doesn't look like
a dangerous fork right but at the end of
this line bishop takes d6 happens
and the rook on e8 is hanging and black
is experiencing a lot of concrete
problems and so in conclusion
in
this position it's very important
to keep this bishop on e4 to move the
other bishop back to f8
and after knight takes d6 the position
finally fizzles out the smoke clears
and this is obviously
a dead draw if your bishop takes e5 even
though technically black wins wins upon
but because of the opposite colored
bishops the queen trade
will be inevitable so is this going to
happen is this exact line going to take
place it's not impossible i mean nils
might go rugby one
uh and andre definitely will see the
idea of knight takes c4 we'll see
yeah and interesting interesting stuff
but it you have to feel like the the
momentum is
shifting and i think niels also has to
to sense that and sometimes it's it's
not easy to give in when you you feel
you were better to then adapt to this
new situation as neil staring at the
position with some big eyes there we'll
see what he comes up with let's go back
to the bird's eye view
let's okay so we have here uh in the top
left oh we have stuff going down in the
magnus vivid game let's
uh bring everybody up to speed on what's
going on
okay well magnus played d4
i mean is this really a surprise to
anybody that he's trying his best
to preserve winning
chances saying i am not going to let you
breathe he goes f4
undermining the e3 pawn
now i think king f2 is a very likely
move by magnus
and this is incredibly complicated i
mean both sides have problems
with their pawn structure now the e4
pawn becomes a liability and so
you know black probably has to go rook a
e8
but
you know white can centralize the king
with king e2
i kind of like this for white believe it
or not i don't see
how black makes progress even though
these pawns look very intimidating fiona
i mean vinida has to be careful not to
overextend himself exactly enough more
that he can chew maybe he already has i
think what you're saying is the pawns
they look intimidating but if they don't
do any actual damage uh then they might
just be weaknesses for for black
yeah and i mean white can play c3 and
reinforce the pawn on d4 as well
yeah and magnus
king f2 is once again is not an easy
move i think to to see especially if
you're just starting out feels so
counter-intuitive to put the king into
the the fire into the line of the rook
on f8
yeah and there's one more thing knight
takes d4 here is extremely tempting
looks like oe3 check fancy stuff
believe it or not black is much worse
than this end game why
well again
it's important not to
not to make conclusions based on the
optical sort of illusion that white's
pawn structure is inferior it's actually
superior the pawn on f4
is as a very serious liability the pawn
on b7 can also be attacked whereas if
you actually look at white's pawns they
are very easy to defend you can play c3
they defend e4 and you can play king d3
in order to defend the c4 pawn black's
king is obviously a lot worse it's on
the king's side and they cannot cross
the f-file again because of that very
weak pawn so i don't know what vidit is
planning against king f2 but that is
such a typical magnus move and your
color arrow game danya i have to say
absolutely on point
thank you yeah i am i'm feeling the i'm
feeling the multicolored errors today
if not king f2 and maybe we can have
look have a quick look at the captures
uh what would happen if white either
captured on f4 or on e4
well let's start with knight takes e4
knight takes c4
is a very plausible candidate move the
idea being to meet f takes c3 with c3
but here i think black has this very
important resource we've talked about
this move before knight a5 uh chipping
away at white spawns from the side and
after c5 knight c4 this is unappetizing
for white because the knight has
anchored itself to the e3 pawn which is
now essentially impossible to win
so
this is an interesting try but
ultimately not
effective and i think taking on f4 is
even less effective on account
of knight takes d4 and white doesn't
even win a pawn i mean white just ruins
his pawn structure
and after knight takes e4 if you want to
be fancy schmancy you could you know you
could take on f4 first and then play
knight e2
and knight takes f4 and it's very
obvious that
black has no problems here
yeah and magnus actually the more we
look at him and maybe if we take a uh
go on to to his cam
uh
just now just as we go there he has
that face of yeah okay well if it has
defended impressively and
i'm not
really seeing much here what do you read
into it
i mean i think after king f2 magnus is
not going to be unhappy with with his
position maybe he's worried about
something
of course he he doesn't want to take any
undue risk
and if he wants to draw
the
easiest way to make it is is probably to
take on f4 after all so
this decision is really going to signify
whether you know what magnus's mentality
is here what is his risk tolerance
in this game
um by the way i don't know if i talked
about it c3 is also a possibility
e3 also possible i don't know we did
talk about it
yeah no we yeah we did we did talk about
this and
one of the things i'm quite impressed
with i thought uh when we we saw the
opening surprise prong by magnus i
thought this is going to be a tough game
for fitted on the clock he immediately
started investing time for move two
um but after that he's done
a really great job to not
let that time advantage get out of
control and now the player is almost
very close to being equal on the clock
sure
yeah they're down to magnus down to 31
minutes if he spends another five
minutes on this move then the time
situation is going to be equal man 25
minutes for 20 moves but this is another
potential time scramble in the making
assuming that the end game remains
complex and i think really for magnus
what he needs to decide is i think he
sees a couple of these lines that could
just fizzle out very quickly and
of course he can sort of make a draw
here if he wants it and i think what he
really needs to debate is
am i taking any risk by is king f2
is there any line there where i could be
in trouble because with the new
tournament situation with danny duboff
being out magnus getting a free point on
the last day
a win today would be fantastic but even
a draw gets him that a little close a
step closer to to his ultimate goal
which is winning this tournament
yeah i mean he's not going to be too
happy with a draw with white and i think
what he's really trying to evaluate is
the move night before this is definitely
the most testing and you know the issue
for white is that after rook fc1
what i'm having a hard time
understanding is okay
let's say black starts with the move a5
just to select oh but now i can play
takes f4
and and and swing the king over to e3
and the thing is
if black plays
rook a8 then i think white should take
the opportunity to play a5
and you know prevent this knight from
being
defended by the apon because if you
don't do that if you go let's say king
e2
and then black goes a5
you're never going to make progress with
white i guess the evil bar once again is
proposing he takes f4 my point was just
that c3 is always met with knight d3
and otherwise it's difficult to make
progress so these kinds of things have
to be properly evaluated and i think
this is what magnus is dedicating the
majority of his thinking time to
what are you expecting are you expecting
king f2
yes i'm fully expecting king f2
so we will see as magnus drops below a
half an hour we'll come back here let's
go back to the overview
okay well we have magnus on our top left
thinking about
uh what to do after f4 and we we see
jordan indeed going bishop d2 bishop b1
so that was his idea his idea was
actually not to use the knight to attack
f6 but rather to use the bishop
and the b1 rook this also looks like a
very reasonable approach and anish still
in a good deal of trouble
then we see that in the nils game
nothing has happened he is still
thinking after knight b2
and pragnanda against fabiano things
have changed a little bit there do you
want to take a closer look yeah
for sure and i think things are changing
in
fabie's favor prague's position has
really deteriorated here fiona he's done
something very strange
i i really dislike
his move knight i mean in this position
we were discussing knight iii and you
know in so far as one could offer a
criticism of prague's play this
tournament
it does seem like in situations where he
had an opportunity to go for the attack
uh you might be thinking about knight h
knight g5 in particular against magnus
and now against fabi knight g3 with a
potential rook lift that looks really
dangerous for black really dangerous but
instead he goes completely the opposite
direction he goes to d4
well and fabio says all right thank you
very much dcbc now he takes the a pawn
he he forces the queen
uh to move away from the battery and now
he solidifies and anchors the bishop
with c5 and he opens up his other bishop
and guess who might be attacking it
could be black uh who ends up uh
attacking white's king's side the knight
doesn't have any good squares i mean i
guess 92 makes sense
uh but among other things fabi could
work on both sides of the board he can
play bishop c2
bishop c6 rather followed by a4 driving
this pawn all the way down to a3
white is worse uh and i think prague has
completely lost the threat of the game
here and i think you really hit the nail
of on the head
with prague not taking his chances when
they are being offered
to maybe go on the attack himself and
uh we saw
for example in the game against magnus
how quickly that backfired when he he
didn't take uh his chance and here it
could be
it could be more of the the same as
suddenly we see with every move the bar
dropping further and further down into
into black's camp
well it makes sense i mean white no
longer has an attack black's pieces are
excellently placed and a great decision
in retrospect by fabi
uh to decline the repetition he can also
play rook e to d8 this is the top
recommendation right now contesting the
d file and i guess that it makes sense
because there's no real hurry
to go bishop c6 but i don't know if
fabio will be able to refrain from the
temptation
uh to play bishop c6 followed by a4 in
either case he's better in both
positions
and yeah just a rough going here for for
prague who's also down to 20 minutes for
14 moves yeah it was just my eye just
went there so
we are just over an hour away from the
first
time control but travel brewing here for
prague on the board and on the clock
will come
come back do you want to jump to another
game straight away or bring back the
bird's eye view to see what's happening
yeah briefly we can bring the view and
grendelius is continuing to contemplate
what to do after 9p2 we will not get
well we'll get to that game when he
makes a decision but for now let's go to
jordan's game
let's see and and look under the
magnifying glass and see how good his
idea is i actually think his idea is
probably as good as knight three i stand
corrected initially i was critical
of 93 but now that i've noticed this
idea
of of staircasing the bishop to h4
and then hitting the f pawn where it
hurts
black is still in big trouble and look
at gary's time situation
yeah i think both are going there again
at the same time
it's even bigger trouble i think
he is clearly the one under pressure
jordan has just sacrificed an exchange
on f6 if you're just joining us um and
he is putting the squeeze on
uh with that bishop maybe we can just go
back a couple of moves to to where we
left it off uh
after knight e3 so what daniel is saying
we were expecting
yeah
the knight to jump to g3 and for the
knight to join the attack but you're
then choosing
another approach which looks as you said
no less dangerous
yeah bishop d2 and now bishop e1 and
okay rook is probably going to come to
g6
the bishop is going to swing to h4
and the really the question that i have
for jordan here is after rook f1 king g7
black is holding on for dear life i mean
obviously black is barely
barely holding on but how exactly is
white going to make progress
in this position yeah you've got this
massive pressure on f6
but what are you gonna do to follow up
on that and i'm having a hard time with
that so
of course jordan maybe he has an idea
here
maybe he just decided i'm gonna get to
this position and intuitively he figured
that he must have something
but i don't know exactly what it is my
first question is that bishop on d3
right now doesn't seem to be doing much
at all i would love to get that like to
h5 or just somewhere closer to the enemy
king basically
no for sure bishop e2 actually i think
is a great move and then queen f2
and you're right on the money bishop h5
or even in some situations bishop g4
could be possible
uh and and the other thing that what
makes it so nasty for black is that
black is no counterplay black is totally
tied down
um these queen side pawns are freezing
any potential attempted counter play
and
man oh man gary definitely
wants something more active than this
but he's not finding anything and he's
now known at 13 and a half minutes yeah
and also one of the nice things for
jordan is he can afford something which
you said a while ago he doesn't need to
immediately find a mating
attack because anisha's piece is also
struggling it's not possible at the
moment for black to organize a counter
strike anywhere that night on a5 really
doing nothing except for looking down at
the pawn
on c4
can black try and
get some counter play on the the queen
side by looking for some a6 b5 or how
does
black react while white is maneuvering
uh his pieces
yeah black can try it but this might
have more harm than good and there might
just not be time bishop h4 rook g6 so
again you could have this
situation i mean the the computer once
again proposes this idea of queen f2
bishop e2 and then bishop h5 piling on
the pressure even further
and even if black plays bishop d7
okay you could throw in rook f1 we we
were of course analyzing a very similar
position
okay if black plays b5 congratulations i
mean what exactly does black accomplish
in fact fiona there is even the tactic
bishop takes v5 and this is what i what
i meant this could actually contain more
harm
than good it does so as long as the king
is on g7 these forking ideas are always
going to prevent
the bishop on d7 from doing anything
other than staring at the f5 square as a
passive spectator and there goes rook g6
and he's finally making a move
you have convincement me i'm a
a6b5 not gonna happen but then my same
question after bishop h4
what are the moves that you make as
black to try and either prepare for the
white attack
or
yeah you you got to play bishop decide i
think you got to go for
for this you just you can't give up f6
that's out of the question
and and so let's say bishop b2 and then
how do you continue the rook from aa
joins the game or well there's a crazy
engine move knight b3
and when you look at it carefully it's
not so crazy black wants to go 92 and
this move is very hard to stop if you
move the queen away 92 is still really
annoying because white loses the e4 pawn
so
with with that in mind bishop c2 is a
very deep prophylactic move so
on the one hand it accomplishes white's
aim white wants to play bishop d1 and
get the bishop to h5 but first you're
preventing the knight from reaching b3
so this might be
uh a more circumspect option
uh option for white just to rule out any
counter plan for black
he just has to move back and forth i
mean rook g8 rook h8
no other pieces are capable of moving
fiona this is among the most depressing
situations that you could possibly have
not to mention the time pressure yeah i
mean what a
a tough situation aneesh finds himself
in
right now jordan he is
super focused he senses that this
position is very promising but also i
think if you're not uh
as white it's easy to make some moves
and suddenly the pressure is
relinquished you really have to play
quite energetically i love
how deep that bishop c2 move is covering
b3 first you're then playing the move we
expected uh bishop h4 yeah this is going
to happen bishop d7 i think and we're
going to see that position on the board
h6
oh
no but queen f2 now that one i don't
really understand i mean queen f2
supports the bishop and then
i mean i guess it doesn't really look
jordan he also looks very surprised
to see rook h6 on the board
but here's the thing like in this
position fiona again let's move bishop
e2
and the secondary point of this move
is to bring the bishop to g4 what does
that accomplish well
if the light squared bishops are traded
black can resign
because the knight is going to forcibly
reach out five or it's going to take up
six and
uh
since black has no healthy moves this
could just end up being completely lost
i mean goodness i think anish is losing
control of the game is rook h6 basically
just losing a tempo
i think it is i think i i think anish
might have just overlooked the move
queen f2 now
his idea might have been to induce queen
g3 or if you can get white to play g3
yeah that's a very weakening move
but i think jordan is going to go queen
f2 and he's going to thank him for it
yeah jordan as soon as rook h6 was
played he immediately he had that look
on his face of like
what
and i think he's just gonna double check
because you never expect your opponents
to
to give you that kind of
opportunity so i think jon is just gonna
make sure that there's no
no hidden traps here and
play queen f2
yeah and uh we will keep an eye on this
but anish in dire straits
this is a huge game for the tournament
standings i mean if jordan wins it
i i wouldn't say that magnus wins the
tournament magnus's game by the way very
likely to enter the draw let's go back
to the bird's eye view i'm quite
surprised with magnus he has decided
against king f2 instead going for the
bailout option rook takes f4
let's have a look
at how that end game is unfolding but
this game is going to end in a draw with
99 certainty fiona as magnus yeah he
takes on f4 in this position of the rook
and we talked about this line knight
takes d4 and i take c4
divided collecting the f4 pawn and
yeah yeah and then they're not being
very much left to play uh for here i
mean i'm not ruling out danya that
magnus walked around the playing hall
saw jordan is in a very good position
against anish and decided okay
with
anish
very likely not going to win
mostly this is a result again for two
results and that
a draw for him uh
is a good a good result and not willing
to take any kind of risks and all but
well said and that's totally under so
and i would also add that after b6 c5 if
anybody has to be careful it is black
magnus has won these types of positions
before
it's it's not out of the question that
that you know bit it is short on time
and you know what's the problem here
well the problem is that if you take on
c5 look at this a6 pawn that's a big
weakness the pawn on a4 on the other
hand is
you know not a target at all it can't be
attacked and white's got control of the
b file so it looks like black has
defines this very accurate move b5 this
is what magnus makes you do he makes you
find these moves
uh and the point is that after eight
takes b586b5 rook takes b5
rook a4
not obvious at all chasing the knight
and the knight just doesn't have any
good squares if you move to c3 you allow
rook c4 if you move to d2
then the rook comes to a2 and takes the
pawn on c2 and
if you defend the knight with your king
then there's a tactical
knight takes g2 but
i don't know if vidid is going to going
to spot this idea this line is the the
detail i guess why not because i was
wondering why not start with rook a2
but then in that line after king f3
there's no knight g g2 is that the
difference
that is the difference in 96 is nicely
met with c3
regarding the d4 pawn and yeah
probably this is still a draw after king
f7 black essentially has a fortress
but magnus can torture it here for for
hours essentially so
uh so it's not over yet and i totally
understand why magnus went for this and
like you said i think he checked out
jordan's game and he said hey this is an
option where i'm not risking at all and
i still have a little bit of pressure
why you know why the heck not exactly
and well we'll see if with it i can find
the most uh precise defense here dania
we're going to take a quick break but
the time control is coming up in just an
hour so things heating up don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
yeah i grew up analyzing with the board
but things are very different now most
of the analysis is done on on the
computer
most of the time i work
with computer with engines ai and its
legacy will be answered
in
the future the engines are so much
stronger than humans that you tend to
believe
what they say change the game
the way we see the game
very differently i sometimes think over
the board and try to you know find human
ideas and also use computer as well
i think i'm more scared in terms of the
future of trust of computers just
processing faster and then if they
become a little bit stronger i worry
that one day chess can be weakly solved
if i don't use technology i'll be just
lagging behind
against all my colleagues because you
have to use it kind of luckily i still
think that day is very very far away and
i think it will be after i'm retired
many many years in the future solving
chess is way way out there and frankly i
hope that it won't be
in a very very long time ai generally
brought new ideas
and a lot of things maybe people would
have discovered eventually but just made
it much much quicker we want to learn
from the best and currently the best is
simply the machines not the humans yeah
we lost this battle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round 11 here at the
tata steel chest tournament dania jordan
and anish are going down the line we
were looking at before the break but
things seem to be going downhill uh very
quickly for anish
yeah they are and you know jordan really
needs to find one more
impressive move after bishop h5
rook h6 well there's a very
no but i think just bishop g4 ends the
game
i think bishop g4 ends the game
um
he's gone h3
i don't like that move i think that
bishop h5 won on the spot
rook h6 bishop g4 i really don't
understand why i didn't go for this i
mean i think h3 doesn't really doesn't
really spoil anything the point is he's
trying to create an anchor point on g4 i
just don't think that's necessary i
think
i mean bishop g4 knight g4 is is just
destruction and this move knight
knight takes c4 saying okay i'm going to
distract this knight from the bishop
well there's one
very small problem uh and that is that
your queen is going to hang at the end
of the line so h3 by jordan
this does give a nice tempo and i think
he could he could use this tempo to go
rook to just a very small problem he
could use this tempo to go rook g8 and
try to escape via f8 it's still lost no
question about it but maybe a tiny
inaccuracy committed by yord and still
shouldn't change the outcome of the game
and we honestly
yeah i was sorry anish no no he was
hovering i think it was about rook g8
was about to be played then dropping
back at the hand and the reminder if
you're just joining us now only 11
minutes on the clock for a niche we'll
move at 27 so 14 moves still to make
furnish
yeah i mean
massive time pressure as well as
a wasp bishop takes h3 danya
no but now but okay but now what if
bishop h5 yeah
no bishop h5 is is i think just came
over
bishop h5
rook h6
g takes
h3 rook takes h5 you take on f6
i mean look at this position i think
even the very simple move king h2 ends
the game because now
black's king simply cannot escape and
why it's going to go rook g1
and again this is the whole point fiona
of this entire attacking sequence it's
that white is in no hurry it's not like
if white doesn't mate on the next move
black's gonna do something black what
makes it so depressing is that black has
no counter play
and jordan can take all the time in the
world to set up this mating net uh he's
playing totally risk-free and i think
after bishop h5 this is pure desperation
for manish uh for manish and jordan just
needs to find one or two more accurate
moves to score an incredibly impressive
victory if you can carry this through
all the way home i mean anyway jordan
was the one who went h3 and
we should have actually looked at that
move but for sure if you play h3 as
white giving your opponent the chance to
take on h3 he had to follow up in mind
that it is on the board bishop h5
yeah we might see a resignation very
very shortly here for anish
uh the other thing is if he moves his
bishop back to d7 then obviously while
there's bishop g6 fg bishop takes f6 and
this is total and utter devastation
after queen h4
anish yeah i think he's going down this
line but
you know the combination of threats
against the king combined with the
weakness of the e5 fund is too much to
bear for black
and bishop d7 has been played
and now bishop g6 basically
um i think what you're saying is the the
end of the game
yeah i mean just a couple more accurate
moves uh are are necessary for you and
i'm sure there's multiple ways to win
um and you know for if we look at it a
little bit more concretely so it takes
takes bishop takes f6 king g8
queen g3
rook e8 all of this is forced and yeah
just driving nope that is not forced
driving the queen into g5
okay let's say black plays knight p7 and
now knight f5 i think ends the game
because the knight heading for h6
forcing the capture and that's it
black's king turns into dust here
one of those types of sequences
is
the likeliest to occur and jordan taking
his time but he's going to take the
record he has just captured on g6
indeed and this is going to be of course
a very hard blow for anish not just
losing this game against his compatriot
jordan there's always a special flavor
to it but especially with the new
tournament situation the fact that
magnus will get a walk-over point in the
the last round and if jordan keeps his
cool here and converts this against
anish i think anish's hopes of of
winning the tournament are sadly over
yeah this is a tremendous game by jordan
and the really the opening choice i've
been very very impressed by it's really
gutsy to play something that isn't
fashionable against an opening maverick
like a niche
uh and to do so and just completely
outplay him anish going for the
traditional setup but he just failed to
get the engine started on you know on
the queen side he didn't really get to
that pawn on c4 and then castling short
was a very provocative it was a it was a
bold move
but uh jordan rook takes f6
uh not an easy move to play but he goes
through with it
and uh barring a miracle this will be
a very impressive display by jordan who
once again is putting together a very
very nice performance in this tournament
he's beaten
he's beat bit it and now he's going to
be geary
yeah and i'm just double checking what i
was saying earlier so i was wrong anish
has not made two but three draws but
three out of ten
ain't much and it's uh soon to be three
out of 11.
wow
well he's a new man what can we say
for sure and here you're suggesting i
think queen h4 or
queen h4 queen g3 i think ultimately the
idea is the same you want to put the
queen on g5 and then play knight f5 now
the problem with going knight to five
immediately is that black takes bishop
takes up i mean you definitely want to
take with the pawn here you can't
because the bishop hangs so
all you want to do is reinforce the
bishop one more time and then
essentially you can pre-move knight f5
black might have to move the rook away
from e8 to prevent that from happening
but of course that gives up this
all-important e5 pawn and just look at
these two connected passers they're
going to tear black limb from limb
uh once the epon starts moving forward
so
jordan knows that you know
he he needs one more accurate move and
he has plenty of time on the clock as
well great time management on top of
everything else by jordan
for sure i mean
you already uh just explained us how
impressive jordan's effort today is
straight from the opening and anish
uh he also looking you know it's not the
usual focus he kind of knows that this
one
is gone
and yeah just for him a tough tough day
while i'm being informed dania that
fabiano
has also i mean he was already taking
over when we left it but
uh he is closing in already on on the
full point
oh well let's swing swing over oh my
goodness a blunder my prague
a blunder by prague pragas plunder to
peace
fabiano could win this game right now oh
my lands look at this look at this
bishop takes c3
you can't take with the queen bishop
takes c3n
bishop
good
and it's he oh no he doesn't win a piece
he doesn't win a piece but he does win
the game queen c1 i apologize it's false
out of her tight i thought queen b3 was
forced
and then fabby plays a4 and he does win
the piece yeah yeah prague can go queen
c1 but here's the thing takes takes a
four look at this pawn that pawn
is just going to be completely
unstoppable in the long run fabi's gonna
put his queen on a8 he's going to send
that pawn forward and at the right
moment the knight is going to emerge
from d7 and win the pawn on c4 this is a
completely winning end game for black
and it's up to fabi to evaluate it
correctly but if he does he is going to
carry home the full point so not a piece
but that a pawn deciding the game in uh
instead fabiano still has 27 minutes on
the clock so plenty of time to figure it
out
if he takes uh on c3 this game
is
pretty much over
let's leave him calculated let's go back
to the to the jordan uh game against
anish
yeah if you're on anyone who has gone
queen h4
and uh now
well fourth uh for anish
just there's basically nothing like none
of the the moves we looked at even
caused some problems you only need to be
careful about this knight f5 not to play
that prematurely but um
that is the last
the other thing jordan might be going
for here is bishop e7
uh and and basically the point is
well you could take with either piece
and then you could uh swoop in with
queen f6 followed by d6
i mean anything wins for white it's
really really difficult to squander this
at this point i think geary might even
resign in this position
uh there's essentially nothing to play
for
um because
there aren't any tricks here
yeah and i my guess is he will
fight today especially more so than
maybe other rounds where
this might be his last chances in this
event let's see very quickly while anish
thinks about this what's happening in
the magnus game has vidit
i found this b6b5 maneuver we were
talking about oh what's going on
well you know things are actually
believe it or not kind of heating up in
that game vidit first of all has 10
minutes for 12 moves second of all
magnus has found a phenomenal
practical chance so bid it in in this
critical position
he went rook f8
magnus trades on b6 now he can't take
twice because of knight d5 check
but he moves he plays c4 uh essentially
preventing b5
and saying that okay you don't really
have any effective discovered checks
vit it does give a discover check on d5
and after king e2
vidit is thinking here's what magnus
wants to do after knight f4 check
i think magnus actually might be playing
for a win with king e3
after knight takes g2 king d4 if vidit
loses the b6 pawn
he could lose this game in two moves
that c pawn
is is a monster somehow magnus is
causing
significant problems for vivid who who's
down to his last 10 minutes for for for
over 10 moves and i mean this is really
vintage magnus it's so incredible we
thought that vidit had done most of the
hard work at the moment uh when magnus
uh when he took on f4
for a second before he's going for the
line that is just going to lead to a
draw without too much action but no it's
never it's never the end with magnus
you've never done enough
and
yeah here forbidded
uh he is far from being in um
what's the in dry
i mean
in dry sheets or something
i think i'm this yeah i'm not very good
with the experiment oh there's another
idea what about rookie eight here
is the key and my idea was if king d3 i
want to play rook takes e4
c takes d5 rook takes a4
okay white's gonna push
oh but there's a problem king f7
white cuts off the king with the rookie
one
oh oh and now d7 is a massive threat
rook a5 trying to go to d5
no that's prevented by white white's
king this might be losing i mean the
king can walk over to c6 and then
support the pawn
and not something you want to go for can
we go back to to that final position how
do you guys blacks yeah that pawn at all
you have to get behind or
you have to get behind it rook 82 and
then white will take this opportunity to
get this king deep into black's
territory
now the problem in such positions for
white is that it's actually not so easy
to promote this pawn because black has
this idea of constantly checking
and then returning to d2 and ultimately
white might be forced to step in front
of the pawn of the king
uh but white is under no obligation to
rush with d7 and bennett has made a move
and that move is rocky rookie he has
played it magnus immediately
immediately
taking the knight this might trans yeah
this is going to transpose
and we're going to go down this line
and this line looks very very scary for
black now
extremely it might be a draw by the
narrowest of margins but
it is very clear that vinit has already
done something wrong and he is hanging
by a thread here in that resulting end
game let's watch king d3
vivid i assume has to take on a4
yeah i see that our engine is suggesting
rook f4 which i cannot make sense of at
all why wouldn't you
take
uh
on on a4 is the engine deeming already
that the rook on a4 is just too badly
placed to deal with the deep honor
what's going on
i think the point is that you're
inducing rick takes b6 and now you're
gonna play rook takes a four okay and
the thing is after d6 king f7 white's in
the previous line white sword could go
to e1 here
as it stands black's king
is able to catch up to the pawn but the
thing is after work out for white
doesn't have to take
and
play the move g3
and and force this rook to commit to a
spot
if the rook
takes uh the king side pawns then again
you're able to go d6 king d5 etc i think
vidit senses the moment he is taking his
time here uh but he's leaving himself
with absolutely no time for the last 10
moves no i
if i mean magnus is just he's a wizard
he's he's a magician it's crazy how he
does this
all the time
and i mean how quickly it happens it's
like we looked at this possession what
five
six moves ago uh with the tension in the
center and i thought okay he's seen a
niche is in trouble it draws a good
result he a couple of natural moves are
played and suddenly i guess both of us
feel like magnus is a huge favorite to
win this game
and that's exactly what he does i mean
he lulls even the strongest opponents
into a false sense of security to a
sense that
okay magnus has really given up hopes of
winning the game
and his ability to create trouble even
in the most symmetrical looking
positions you know what was deceptive
about that was how symmetrical it was it
was knight rook and four versus night
rick and four but obviously
uh there was that weak pawn on b6 and
everything revolves around that pawn as
vidit is down to six and a half minutes
my guess is he might play rook out for
he might spot that idea
but i just i mean if he survives this uh
with this amount of time
that would be just miraculous at this
point
yeah and you've got to feel for vidit
who was
the one of the earliest leaders in the
tournament he had such a great event and
then two days ago we saw really
he lost that marathon
battle against prague where he was
fighting
so fiercely for so long but then it
wasn't
quite enough
and today suddenly we see as well there
with the close-up of fitted head in
hands
and he might have another very very
unpleasant uh defensive task ahead of
him and another rock ending
indeed this would be a very very painful
loss
um we also see fabiano he has gone for
the for the line that we outlined and uh
he uh again barring something crazy he
should be able to win the win the game
and that would be a huge result for fabi
uh a big bounce-back win
after his disappointing loss to report
in the previous round
we also
can i just say that i think i i would be
in a way happy to see fabiano get that
big win uh as black get his spirits up
ahead of what will be
magnus's last game of the tournament
tomorrow he will be playing black
against fabiano so still a big big
matchup to look forward to
indeed and fabi is going to pull out all
the stops he's going to do his best
especially if he wins
today he's going to have the white
pieces
uh and that will be one to watch jordan
by the way playing a really nice move an
alternative to what we were discussing
and vidit hasn't gone rook for but taken
on a4 but yeah let's start with jordan
and then maybe we can go back to uh to
carlson
he's just played queen sheep by the
point of rook f3 just to put the rook on
a defensive squad on a square where it's
protected the pawn on e5 is about to
fall and with it
the whole position topples over
the e5 passer is rumbles down the board
i don't see
a single chance here for a niche yeah
and i mean i see that our engine says
the best move is
knight b3 but knight b even knight b3
doesn't even create any kind of
well this is the idea actually it it
does
because the point is now like the bishop
can't well the bishop can move and it
actually should move
but there are some concrete difficulties
here remaining to solve the engine line
is bishop f6 queen takes e4 and now back
to e5 i always love this motif
uh and the point is rook takes f3 gf
is forced and black is unable to prevent
the queen from infiltrating
2d8 let's see what anish did queen of
faith he has played queen fade yeah
that's a nice move
piling up on the bishop
and what if bishop takes e5
i guess here
yeah i think bishop e5 is the winning
move because you can't play queen takes
f3 between the eight checkmates
i think this is what's going to happen
yeah you're gonna take some queen though
oh queen takes
i don't know that knight b7
i mean still completely winning
because the queen just going to move
back and then send the epon forward
i like that knight be7 is on the board
but i love your suggestion of just
getting the king the queen out of the
way and then
using four central pawns
queen f4 and i think anisha is going to
resign if jordan plays queen foreign he
is
there's
very little to i think so too especially
after the speed with which uh he took on
e5 with the queen
because both moves i think were very
tempting both moves were winning queen
captures and bishop captures but i think
if you capture so quickly with the queen
you really have a follow-up in mind
already
yeah and the reason you actually don't
want to play queen g5 here which may
seem more natural is because after
knight d6
uh the the e4 square is hanging like e5
allows knight e4 you don't want to do
that
and so in this case you actually do want
to pin yourself
knight d6 e5 98
and you know the funny idea here is to
send the g-pawn up the board to
reinforce the bishop so that you can
then play e6
i mean this is all child's play for
jordan these are all very very easy
you know kind of one move ideas
uh and he's just making sure that he
doesn't do anything to squander this
excellent game that he's played yeah i
think uh i saw a couple of hours ago
someone said could this be jordan's
immortal i think it's definitely gonna
rank up there with some of the best
games he's played
yeah this was such a smooth one rook
takes f6 incredibly textbook thematic
sacrifice always nice to win a game
uh with this kind of purity right that's
a pure
traditional uh old school sacrifice
followed up by an exquisitely connected
attack and he just needs one or two
accurate moves he's got 20 minutes
remaining and you know the all of these
players are so patient none of them
you know play impulsively
uh and that's always refreshing to see
and you know the younger generation can
definitely learn something from that for
sure and you're then he is not going to
rush but
uh queen f4 followed by the advance of
deepon
and it looks like there will be no hope
for black maybe we have time for a
second to bring back the overview while
uh jordan is pondering
yeah i mean magnus and
are going down the line that we outlined
rookie one who's just been played
cutting off the king
so vivid already hanging by a single
thread that's over on your top left
uh jordan as we just discussed is
putting the finishing touches on his win
against the niche and grindelwald is
it's been a while since we looked at
that that's been a pretty insipid game
actually once it's stabilized i think
the position there is very even we have
oppositely called bishops
um
shall we check into that game really
yeah let's do it very quickly and i'm
sure our producer vic will keep a close
eye on oh yeah especially jordan against
danish which very likely is the first
game to
to end here but let's catch up with
niels and andre
yeah so after knight b2 niels played
knight g5 i really liked that move
heading for e6 and
uh you know because of that threat andre
decided to capture the knight
but the danger of giving up the dark
squared bishop is that d6 becomes even
more of a concerning target especially
if the bishop returns to f4 knight d3
work f3
95 rook a3 nil swinging his rook hither
and the other queen b7 and now after
rook b3 queen c7 he drops the bishop
back to f4 now i think white is slightly
better actually i think on on second
thought i agree with the eval bar i
think white is slightly better and the
reason why is that niels might follow
this up with rookie three in fact rookie
three is a very powerful positional
threat
and black should probably go knight f7
preemptively
uh as a way of of taking the sting out
of the move rook e3 but obviously with
the pressure on d6 as powerful as it is
black really doesn't have any play and
neil says a lot of ways he can improve
his position like he can play king h2
he can get his knight around to f3
andre needs to be very careful here as
he has gone
queen a5 going for active defense
a5 so putting uh attacking the the pawn
on a2
which i guess we have to do something
about that's not a pawn we can afford to
lose
yep that is not a point i mean rook a3
would repeat the position
i think
or no it technically would i mean the
rook has come from a3
but after rook a3 the queen would swing
over to b4 and i feel like niels has to
go back to b3 so maybe
you want to play
pawn a3
maybe that's the way to play but hill's
now down to seven minutes so i'm sure
he's also enticed by
the possibility of repetition we'll see
he's about to make a move so let's
say no none of the two moves instead
queen c3
offering the queen trade
and that's a really interesting one what
niels is saying is that even in the end
game the weakness of d6 is going to be
concerning it's important not to visu
not to fall into the illusion that black
is better because he's got the nicer
knight that knight on e5 can be captured
at any moment
and it's it's not a a safe night at all
white can keep pressuring it in many
different ways so
sorry
distracting us here
that's a hilarious image
it is a hilarious image unfortunately
it's nowhere near uh as much fun for uh
for anish maybe we can quickly and then
we'll come back to this and have a
closer look at queen c3 but was it
amnesia's move in this moment as we see
that andre not interested in the queen
trade dropping the queen back i don't
know where to go shall we stay here
should we
let's go to an issues game and jordan
has been taking a very long time here
contemplating what i thought he would
play almost instantly the move queen f4
if we look at our bird's eye view yeah
let's stick to our magnus we'll have to
go back there as well yeah we're we're
we're pulled in all different directions
fabi by the way as we have discussed he
went for that line but he has to play
accurately in order to convert that past
a pawn into a win
um let's go to magnus's game actually i
i feel like we need to figure out
whether that's actually winning or drawn
and this is obviously the most important
game of the tournament right now so this
is the position on the board
now again
white does not want to rush d7 this
would actually be a terrible idea
because black gives the check and the
king has nowhere to go rook d2 and
eventually the king will have to walk uh
to d a which is counterproductive so
it's important to keep the pawn on d6
in order to give the king shelter
on d7 the engine proposing rookie seven
checking f6
and now the move rook back to e4
now what is the idea oh so let's say
black drops back to f7 right
now white plays d7
white goes down this line boom boom boom
oh and i get it so here's the point of
putting the rook on e4 if black just
plays a5
then
white plays rook f4 check
and king e8 and by the way this is not
it's not a given that this position is
an easy win but it i think it should be
when i feel like
white's king is gonna end up close
enough to the pawns uh to restrain them
by by one tempo but
this has to be calculated very carefully
by magnus
magnus who is just about to make a move
oh well okay he's going for the same
ultimately the same position
rook c2 check
king b7 rook d2 king c7 rook c2 checking
india this will happen on the board now
that it will have to push response what
minute has to say is yes i'm going to
allow magnus to promote but i'm going to
bank on my past pawns to provide me with
enough counterplay rook f1 check
and
if king e6 king e8 rook da
magnus could throw in a rookie one check
in order to get this king as far away as
possible
from
these past pawns so that the king can't
support them and i think magnus has
calculated this line and decided
that he is winning here that the pawns
are not going to be able to advance
very far in this line there was
something better than king e6 right so
that's when the bar apparently king g6
is a much superior move but let's wait
until this happens and then we'll delve
into why that's the case i'm not sure
that i trust the eval bar here yeah it's
uh
tough to say because the bar that you're
just referencing it's plummeted all the
way i had a quick look at the chat hole
i could see his magnus blundering this
magnus blunder right right right of
course
no but i understand why magnus
understands that he can promote the pawn
so i'm not understanding why this is a
blunder just yet
could it be that could it have anything
to do with that here the black pawns
were somehow faster in that end game no
probably not
well let's have a look so so this is all
happened this is move 38 so
vidit is going to make time control
and now probably rook d2
or or b4 or the immediate before
okay so let's say before it happens
check
king g oh
i see what the problem is now if king e7
there's rookie two check
there is rook e2 check and this is the
whole point when the king was on e6 you
didn't have access to the e file and now
you have this issue right rook comes
back to d2 and white can't really make
progress
oh my goodness
this is
yeah this if that is in fact the case
and if this is actually just a draw then
that was a massive oversight by magnus
who just played too quickly yeah i was
actually just going to ask you
uh do you think magnus played d7 too
quickly which apparently we are getting
confirmation that that was indeed a
blunder it was a blunder it was a
blunder and you know who am i the chat
was right all along dania
it was as always and you know normally i
don't like to criticize magnus but in
this case i will i mean
he definitely
i i think he just got excited he was in
the moment he was feeling it
uh he was very confident and i think
there was a detail here that he
overlooked it might be that he just
forgot the king could step aside to g6
maybe he only considered because king e6
is the natural way to play right
advancing toward the pawn and it's so
easy to forget that the king can move
away from the pawn and leave the rook
this extra space
to give that crucial check to the king
as vidit taking his time on this very
important 39 movement appears that b4
is the
surest pathway to a draw
and with it you can almost
tell a difference in body language from
the last time
we checked in here he is getting a
second uh chance
let's see if he can find this crucial i
think b4 but then king g6 is where the
game will be decided
shall we see if uh if there's been any
update in jordan against anisha in
prague against fabiano
yeah there has been an update in
jordan's game again we're expecting
resignation any moment jordan converting
it exquisitely he has gone queen f4
uh and and then he just pushed the e and
d pawns all the way through that's up in
your
uh top top left there let's get to that
game d6 has just been played by jordan
what is the point of that move the point
of that move is to vacate the d5 square
for the knight and you can see where
that knight is going anisha has to take
on f6
and and probably play bishop c6 to
prevent knight d5 but guess what knight
t5 might be prevented but knight g4 is
not and you could play this move even
though the rook is hanging because after
knight h6 check knight takes f7 check
the most beautiful and fastest win is
look at this move d7 beautiful queen d7
queen b8 with a background checkmate
that's a stunning finish
but very very nice for sure
and this is the game is over
the game is simply over we still haven't
made for anyone wondering we are on move
uh 30 well this was move 37 so any still
has
four four moves uh to make but this is
over now but also not too much more time
for a niche to um
sometimes i think i was going to say not
to think about it but sometimes
they just sit and think about what could
have been as we see a result didn't see
that one coming a drawer agreed between
niels guandellis and andreas pankov
okay i mean you'll still
want to you know
neil didn't want to press his luck here
with four minutes uh for four moves
completely understandable decision
completely understandable because
ultimately white might be slightly
better due to the pawn on d6 but entree
has a lot of peace activity
and it's very easy to lose control of
the game and time pressure anneals with
a solid draw
and yeah totally understandable oh they
actually went for the repetition
it was actually not an offer they they
repeated it and they repeated it
queen d8 heading for h4
neil's stopping that well queen goes to
the other side
queen going to h4 back to g3 and a very
unique repetition another game in the
books this might be a quick round
because prague i was just going to say
that
are on the verge of ending and we see
that vidit has indeed gone before and
now is right about where it might start
joining on on magnus that he did play
indeed d6 prematurely uh if it finds
king g6 but i think he
i think from a distance it was not clear
what's the difference but once you go
down the line you get to the point where
rook f1 appears i think
then it is way more obvious that you
shouldn't
offer shelter to to the white king
you bring up a great point and this is
the worst thing about blunders like
these it's not like there's any question
i mean king it's it's lunacy to play
king e6 in this position i mean allowing
king e8 vinid of course
is going to play king g6 and essentially
is forced so magnus
he
sometimes is very emotional when he
blunders on the rare occasions that he
blunders
so we'll keep an eye on his body
language but he is going to be furious
with himself after the game because
essentially a win would have put the
tournament in the bag i mean the
tournament is still close to being in
the bag but man
there's still some intrigue left
a little bit of intrigue especially
given that he will be playing fabiano
with the black pieces uh tomorrow which
on paper is the toughest uh pairing he
could have in this whole field
yeah
yeah incredible
incredible and then huge kudos to it by
the way for
not losing not losing his heart and
staying in the game
and uh and exploiting the mistake yes
you know one could argue that he got
fortunate but
i always believe in capablanca's
aphorism that good players are lucky uh
you got to put yourself in a position to
get lucky against the world champion and
that's exactly what he did
for sure as magnus 15 minutes at this by
the way is moved 39 so
king g6 if wicked phone appears will be
move 40 so not only
that but widget will also get an extra
50 minutes um
we'll come back here because as magnus i
think understands what he has done
uh let's go back to jordan against
aneesh which i still think is the game
that's likely to finish first out of the
the tree
well
anish down at two minutes on his clock
he is trying to pull out all the stops
here but he's overwhelmed by these
passers and by the knight that's
you know running amok here on d5 and g4
and
you know jordan taking a stroll around
the playing hall waiting for an ish to
to make his last couple of desperation
moves now he could go bishop e6 trying
to prevent
both knight sally's at the same time
but you know the thing is even knight d5
is winning because even even this
position is i mean look at these pawns
these and black can't move rook d7
there's queen e5
and if you play queen takes d6 obviously
there's queen eight track and rook takes
d6 allows f7 tricks so black is totally
paralyzed here and the queen inexorably
a one way or another white is going to
find a way to break through
yeah and uh it's it's tough looking
looking at an ita niche reminder magnus
on the last one we'll get a full point
also here although magnus has squandered
what looked like
close to winning ending into what now
seems to be a draw uh even that magnus
is probably going to get half point
today and zero and um that will and his
chances will look at the standings later
on as anish takes down to a minute and
he played what queen e
no but now knight d5 yeah
yeah just 95.
knight d5 and that knight has done a
little bit of hopping but it's now going
to come
in with a decisive
effect here
i think anish wants 95 queen e2
and there's still a couple of pitfalls
to avoid for jordan i mean if he goes
rookie 3 here
yeah i mean queen d1 check
king h2 the point is there's queen h5
check so
white can sidestep the checks by putting
the king on f2 and then walking it to g3
so everything is winning but you know
it'll take a couple more moves probably
before black's uh final chances are
totally exhausted
and i think jordan he is doing
everything right he is not rushing
he still has 14 minutes on the clock he
only needs to make one more move
and then he'll get an extra 50 minutes
so
there is no need to rush he won't rush
and
anishi is looking over
at what's going on elsewhere because he
knows in his own game unfortunately
there is nothing much left to hope for
yeah i mean there's all sorts of mating
uh nets as well related to knight coming
to e7 and the queen coming to h6
it's lost from every perspective you're
down material you're getting mated uh
any end game is lost because of the past
pawns and there's no counterplay it's
like the worst possible combination of
things is an ish drops down to 30
seconds in comes the queen
but it's
uh not going to help he goes queen you
want check
i mean okay king h2
king h2 and there's no more checks and
this is move 40 for jordan another 50
minutes added to his clock i don't know
how long anish wants to suffer here
honestly i mean suffering in these
positions is so difficult
king h2 there he goes
i think just very often especially when
your time is low at least you play on
until move 40 and you think okay i can
even when you know the position is lost
you can you always think i can assess on
40 once i have time and you just play on
because there is nothing much else to do
you don't have time to commiserate
well not committed be miserable and very
about
the game so we see anitra's make his
40th move
win
queen d1
yeah i mean inertia in their shop and
carries you forward
through move 40. now it appears that the
simplest win is to play queen h6 first
okay black has to buy black has to do
nothing
and then they move rookie three
aiming for e7 is one way to end the game
okay black can trade queens and claim
that he's traded queens and the funny
thing is here yeah white can play rookie
seven and end the game or
why can't black is totally paralyzed and
then just walk the gang up to g5 one way
or another jordan is going to find
one of these options
okay shall we check into prague's game
because it's been a while since we
looked at fabiano's conversion here
and fabiano should win this game
in
short order
the point is that he's gotten his pawn
all the way to a2 where it cannot be
attacked it is defended by the queen
safely
and all he has to do
is get this knight active get it to b4
get it to f5
get it somewhere and white's defenses
will be overloaded what's the square
that you would be if you could go get
anywhere would it be b4 or which square
would you be aiming for aiming for
that's a great question you know i would
even consider getting it to b6
so that i can then play queen a6 and
target the pawn on c4 if you lose that
pawn then you lose the game as well now
it all seems to start with knight g6 and
then knight e7 so for example let's say
i play oh no f4 there's queenie one
chuck so that's just a case in point
this shows how tied down white is
maybe uh prague is trying to get his
king
all the way across and contest the the
a2 pawn this is not very realistic
though
knight h4 check
king e2 the knight could go after these
pawns as well uh but we'll see we'll see
how how fabby
decides to to go about this he's got 10
minutes for
uh for three moves yeah and this is the
kind of position where uh
for prague they're just not only is the
position lost but there are no chances
uh your bishop from a1 is stuck there
forever stopping the black
pawn from queening you kind of wish that
you didn't have that pawn on e5 so you
could at least try and create
some threats along the long diagonal but
that pawn is blocking your and bishop
um all the pieces are paralyzed so there
is i think just zero zero hope for
pranking
yeah he's gonna keep playing as he
should of course fabia has to
demonstrate
uh a couple more accurate moves but the
results in
really all three of the the rest of the
games are
i wouldn't go so far as to say
predetermined but
all of these games are pretty close to
their conclusion yeah let's see what
magnus has done let's go back to to that
okay well he's gone rookie 7 check
and vidit has executed the 40th move
king f8
i thought initially that magnus white
might want to go rook rookie 4 but but
simply b3 and
if anything white's just playing with
more and more fire letting the spawn
further and further down the line i
think magnus going to repeat moves make
a drop i think magnus is just going to
go rookie a check and bite the bullet
here
yeah well he might just not have a
choice i think he understands the fact
that he he didn't give the the check on
f3 shows you that he
saw now that king g6 would lead to
nothing and
um
as you say if he understands that there
are no tries that if he tries suddenly
the black pawns might start rolling down
the board and then he has to anywhere
anyway find a perpetual he might as well
take that immediately
right
and that leaves us i mean it's kind of
today it's been
really done a very strange day where we
might just
uh be done very soon
we might be done you know we might be in
10 minutes uh it really depends on i
think the prague game is the likeliest
one to go on the longest
because
in that game the technical stage for
fabi is a lot more difficult than
for jordan even if the evaluation is
similar and fabio's just made a very
interesting website g5
uh clamping down
on white's king's side let's go back to
that game for just a second especially
since by the way prague only has one
minute for two moves still to make yeah
well i really like that move actually i
like the move g5 this opens up a lot of
luft for the king
and it it sort of discourages white from
pushing any of his king side pawns fabi
definitely wants to follow up
with uh the move knight g6 and then he
wants to maneuver the knight around
through e7
uh to greener pastures
and prague doesn't really have any moves
he has to just sort of go back and forth
what happens if you try like you're
saying if you try to run with the king
towards the the queen side
yeah that might be the most practical
attempt
i i guess knight g6 should be thrown in
and after king e2
yeah well i don't know exactly maybe
knight h4
but then when it goes g3 prague has made
a move h and it's h4 trying his best to
create king side counter play
and um well after that only one moves
one room
[Laughter]
one move remains for frank
[Music]
that was unexpectedly hard
well it can strike at the in the
strangest times you know the weirdest
words
um h4 what does fabi do does he take on
h4 does he leave the pawn standing
well there is an engineer where
apparently black has to move queen e1
apparently
this line with h5 in this position is
winning for black because the king is
just too weak it the king in the long
run here is not going to be able to
escape the wrath
of the queen and the knight i don't
think i was never going to do this
saying i don't even understand why and
now h oh and now h4 and h3 is
unstoppable that's the idea
wow
okay and that involves giving away the
pride of your position for that
uh i don't know if he's gonna do that i
mean i think knight g6
is uh the likeliest human move and then
maybe prague wants to try taking and
going i don't know maybe king g4
uh you might as well go down go down
fighting you know
so there's some life left in this
position some uh
accuracy is still required of fabi no no
doubt about that
i am so i mean if fabi takes on h4 and
goes for that line where he gives up
uh gives up the pawn on a2 to swing the
queen all across to the other side of
the board that would be so impressive of
course it's not the only way that leads
to a win i'm very curious what he's
gonna go for let's bring back the
overview once again to see
is magnus magnus is still thinking
jordan is also still thinking so
everyone
uh
everyone's still thinking but
magnus magnus was away from the board
okay so magnus has just
gotten back um
do we stay with fabiano
do we look at magnus's camera and just
try and get a read on that
yeah let's look at the camera for a
second
he's twirling a piece around but i i
feel like he's
the thing is it's not one of those
positions where
you have a choice between going for a
risky continuation and making the draw
there is no risky continuation there's
literally
nothing that i see
which poses even the slightest challenge
to what to black for because for black
everything is absolutely forced
yeah maybe do you want to bring up the
the board
very briefly or shall we wait for
fabiano
let's let's bring up the board um let's
bring up the board i mean magnus has 50
minutes to think about this i don't
anticipate him taking all of it
so here's the thing
you can think about this well how is
white going to get the king out of d8
well you can't get the rook off of c2
there's just no way to do that so that
means you have to play king e8 to do
that you need to dislodge black's king
from the f-file how can you do that well
you can do that by going rookie three
and if
no but it's important careful yeah
if black is not careful he can lose so
let's say black plays a5
sorry fiona didn't mean interrupt yeah
yeah no so i was
i was wondering when when the bar jumped
i was wondering is the difference we
need to be able to go to g6 and then i
wondered why can't i just
stay on on g8 and i guess you're about
to show us
yeah it's this move rook f5 and if you
just blindly keep pushing why does black
is going to build a bridge rookie 2
checking d6 looks like everything is
fine just keep checking no
rook
blocks the checks on d5 and white wins
so
magnus might try this
magnus might try this rookie 3 is a very
tricky move
what black needs to do is play g6 here
of course vivid is going to see that
this essentially just prevents
white from building that bridge from
putting the rook on f5 and it creates
love for the king
can i not go king f7 are we not back in
the
previous position or what am i missing
well now rick have to recheck oh yeah
and king g6 yeah yeah you can do that
too no that's also possible it's the
same and it's the same exact concept the
king prevents the rook from uh making
its way to f5 that ultimately is white's
only attempt why i can try g4
and after f5 rook f5 oh here black
actually manages to push that beep on
all the way forward and now neither side
can make progress so there's a lot of
ways that the game can liquidate into a
draw this is probably what's going to
happen one of these
pathways is going to be adopted fabi has
taken on h4 by the way oh my goodness oh
my god
that is crazy is he gonna play
one
maybe he's seen it i mean the thing is
white is so dominated in that resulting
position if fabi saw the idea of going
h5 h4 then he's got no he went knight g6
knight g6
yeah shame on him how could he miss this
obvious uh obvious idea
but knight g6 should do the should do
the job
uh as well
as uh we've had
a couple of moves as well in the jordan
game but daniel we've reached the time
control in every game we're going to
take a very quick break because we
expect some results to come in soon but
don't go anywhere we'll be back shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hello and welcome back to round 11 here
at the tata steel chest tournament where
dania only three games remain you were
telling me a minute ago
jordan has a really beautiful win here
and he has founded rook h3 is on the
board what a move and the concept is
even nicer bishop takes h3 this is a
deflection sacrifice
a d7
and the queen's pathway to b8 is
unstoppable if you take on d7 queen b8
check ends the game immediately
and if you play rook f8
the the
problems come from the other end of the
board boom
white sacrifices his final minor piece
well this is a lobster pincer mate and
if black declines the sacrifice after
knight takes f8 it is all over king f8
and among other things just queen b8
check and you can make
a second
queen jordan just this is
this is actually amazing and this might
be the game of the tournament i mean
so many incredible ideas and
capitalizing it and finishing it all off
with uh this kind of combination anish i
i know i've said this many moves in a
row but she might resign here
once he recognizes that he's got nothing
left to fight for
i mean rook h3
is really an incredible move to top off
what has been a an incredible game by
jordan
as you said a clear candidate for game
of the tournament
and i'm curious what ljurden will have
to say
is this going to be one of his best
games of his career so far
looks like it could be
beautiful
amazing move and
fearless too you know it's it's easy to
convince yourself
not to go for something like this when
you're winning you don't want to spoil
it with a miscalculation but jordan
believing in i mean this is for for
someone of his caliber this is easy to
calculate there's
there's clearly nothing because black
doesn't even have a check after bishop
takes d7
and it's yeah you can see that it's all
written all over his face it's all over
yeah that face is not thinking about oh
what in this position what can i do here
this is like where did it all go wrong
where did i go wrong very clearly was it
the opening did i play the wrong system
why did it get bad so quickly
um why did i castle short maybe that's
why what he's asking himself well what
possessed me to castle short
and i mean it could be a lot of things
yeah the way that uh jordan reacted we
were all so dis well not all so
disappointed but i think a lot of people
were disappointed when the exchange sack
uh
didn't happen the first time but the
second time around
jordan went from it and from there on
out i mean there has been some really
stunning
moves and tactical motifs in in this
game
there really have been
um
well uh we will
wait for anish to resign i mean he's got
plenty of time now to contemplate the
position
uh magnus has played rookie three and as
i was talking about this i was actually
in my mind thinking about magnus's
position can we go back to that for just
a second i want to show something
so
here vidit has a choice between king f7
and g6 i feel like g6 is the more
clinical move just because it it takes
away the square with the pawn
but i had an idea uh that i wanted to
explore which is that okay
white can't get the rook to f5 right but
what if white tries to get the rook to
f6 what if white plays g4
now again g5 would relinquish the f5
square you don't want to do that black
should probably play a5
no but white white is not in time
because black pushes the pawn and if
anything
if any
if anything white and white actually has
only one way to draw i think which is
rook f7 check
what a move
and and the uh renegade rook
allows white to draw the game by
stalemate but magnus will not subject
himself to this
what a crazy line this is
that's hilarious
so do you think um g6 we're more likely
to see than king f's like king f7 back
yes
i think we are and another thing to
point out g6 rookie six immediately
uh allows vidit to push his pawn down to
b3
and the point is that if you go after
this point that's not important the
number of pawns isn't important here so
much as advancing one of the pawns down
to b2
both sides are completely tied down
and neither side can make any progress
the king can move away but only for a
second it'll have to move back
it's there's nothing left to play for
here
just one move away from making the draw
is vedic
and magnus he will be kicking himself
but it will be some uh relief
for him when he sees that anish is in a
losing position because i think magnus
he had two clear goals here coming into
the tournament the first and most
important of course winning the event
and he is today taking a big step
despite the missed opportunity and
the one thing he won't be so pleased
about is his quest for 2 900 as he uh
drops a big opportunity here for uh for
the full point against with it
yeah we should add that he has not lost
on time it's just that he needs to make
his 41st move for the time to update uh
so he's got oodles and oodles of time
he's got
he's got 45 minutes he's made move 40
which means that the time edition has
happened automatically
exactly and we see a village and right
behind him i think if the camera zooms
over a tiniest bit on the right we see
that both of them are deep in fought but
uh
a very different kind of thought fitted
is actually calculating while
and it is the final stage of coming to
terms um
with this game being gone i i mean it's
just taking a very long time to figure
stuff out there but i was expecting him
frankly to resign
immediately after rook h3
but again dwelling on how the game has
gone wrong
and that's a common common thing you'll
see and funnily enough at any level
on the widgets table we see that the
glass is still there and the final sip
was never consumed
oh wow maybe he's saving it he was
saving it for a rainy day and that rainy
day might have arrived i mean he's just
he deserves it
maybe after he finds g6 that's when
we'll take that sip
magnus says no you shall not look at
vitid stroker any longer
yeah he's too disgusted of the position
to let the spectators look look through
the camera
magnus sits back down with it is still
thinking uh you expect g6
and
we shall see anish also still thinking
there maybe we expect no more moves at
all
yeah and it's just by now taking 10
minutes this position
yeah there is i mean he's already he
already knows that he can resign he's
just
sort of
i mean i i think he's just very
disappointed to lose this game i mean he
really was not expecting
of all the games that he can lose i
really think psychologically
this was not a game he thought he could
really lose not because jordan this is
not a knock on jordan jordan is
obviously a beast it's just that anish
is so solid when he wants to be
um and and i still think he's he's
coming to terms with
not only the fact that he lost but the
fact that he got crushed in this game
this was a crushing win by jordan yeah i
mean anish never really found his
footing uh in the game i'm curious what
jordan will and there is the handshake
resignation by aneesh
and congratulations
uh to jordan who just played an super
super impressive game
yeah he did as we see them
discussing discussing the moves and this
is definitely going into the game
collection
jordan the winner of last year's status
deal
is once again uh showing
why he not only belongs
in the 2700 club but is thriving as a
member of the 2700 club defeating
anishigiri in
phenomenal sparkling style with a
flourish and a cherry on top that move
rook h3 so nicely executed and magnus
carlsen you saw him stopping by checking
out the game his rivalry with anish giri
is
well documented so you can just kind of
imagine once jordan gets up from his
chair he will receive some warm
congratulations from his boss magnus
carlson
magnus will be very very happy to see
that result and it really takes the
it takes the onus off of magnus it makes
magnus's result uh less painful for him
as that half point is going to put him
even further into clear
first and on that note i mean we've
basically discussed we've exhausted i
think magnus's game um i i think vidit
understands that it's a draw he's just
i mean he just doesn't want to squander
that opportunity and so he's
you know quadruple and quintuple
checking the same line over and over
again
and as he does that perhaps we can look
at the fabby game and
uh take a look at
uh prague's suffering and his
uh he's definitely in dire straits and
and yeah fabi has chosen the move h5
which is completely reasonable i mean
he's preparing to play h4 at the right
moment i mean he doesn't have to rush
with that move the queen can infiltrate
to d2 and white is completely tied down
so in the long run i just don't see this
happening for prague
yeah i mean even here what do you do do
you just go back again with the king
like you're so tied down that it's even
tough to to make a move at all
yeah king h2 and here fabi will
definitely go queen d2 in order to
attack the f2 pawn
um
what's funny is that no matter where
white moves the queen
okay so here after queen c2 fabi i think
this time he will he will see this idea
now with the pawn on h5
this is very findable
uh because the pawn just goes to h3 by
force
yeah no i mean there's nothing can do
about it if he moves the bishop then he
allows promotion
and if he moves the queen elsewhere he's
gone
by
okay so queenie one ends the game here
oh also queen d8 queen d8 is another
possibility
with the idea of
checkmating white on g4 forcing
okay this forces the king to drop back
oh queen age four queen takes c4
beautiful
that's that billboard awareness strikes
again
queen d8 ends the game on the spot
actually just on the spot because once
frog loses c4 he's going to resign
and fabby sees it i have no doubt that
he's going to play queen d8 i can almost
guarantee it
queen d has gone king f7 by the way oh
so not g6 but king f7 we thought also is
enough now we're back in the same
position we were in earlier where magnus
tried
or key seven maybe we can bring it up
for a second as fab it's the same yeah
it's the same exact thing the only thing
that concerned me about this was this
move g4 that i outlined in order to pave
the way
for the rook to come to f5 but if you
actually look at this concretely rook f5
there is this move b3 very important for
black not to procrastinate on this to
play b3 at the first opportunity and
once again we are very familiar with
this type of position which
is an immediate draw
do you think
i guess magnus will try this line if not
there are no other attempts right
no there's zero there's literally zero
attempts i mean you could play g4 first
and uh vidit's default is just to push
response that's also what makes this so
easy for black black doesn't have a big
choice like black just pushes his pawns
okay maybe magnus could try something
like this
but
here there's rook c3 and if anything
once again white is just
playing with fire i think magnus is
going to repeat moves with rook f3 check
and work back to e3
and yeah this will be a great hold uh by
visited as fabiano he is still thinking
both of these
games could end momentarily with magnus
is he going to make this final ditch
attempt with
g4 um but he is not going to be happy
especially that
in this the sun game here and we see
that jordan and anisha are still at the
board discussing their own game
but
for magnus it is frustrating of course
that he let the opportunity slip and
that in this position there is simply
no more
he's gonna run out of attempts um
within a couple of years
and once again if i can rewind to the
moment where magnus blundered
uh the move d7 is hasty right it seems
totally natural to push the pawn but
what the move does is it deprives the
king
of this very important shelter square on
d7 and apparently the correct move was
rookie 7 check posing black with a very
nasty dilemma either direction contains
major drawbacks king f6
rookie 4. i mean let me be very clear
winning this position was no easy matter
even if magnus had found the correct
path i mean i don't even fully
understand how this all works and then
at the end fiona magnus would have to
correctly assess
uh he would have to
promote at the right moment
and restrain the pawns in the right way
which is always very scary when you have
double pass connected passers
the rook could end up getting
overwhelmed so you could be in danger of
losing i can't really blame magnus for
not finding all of this
i suppose he's just gonna be mad at
himself for playing so quickly yeah also
well in hindsight i'm thinking how much
time did magnus even have on the on the
clock because both of the players maybe
we
i don't know if we didn't pay much
attention to the clock time so if the
players had enough but it could be
magnus didn't have uh plenty of time
that's for sure to to calculate this and
we don't know it could be that he
considered the alternative but just
couldn't calculate the black pawns
advancing and so little time
and maybe yeah maybe he also saw that
this is a risk-free option he knows that
he has a draw in his pocket whenever he
wants it um we already know that this
was his approach going into this game
not taking undue risks but i think it
came as a disappointment to him that
upon reflection he realized that he
actually doesn't have any winning
chances at all which perhaps came as a
surprise to him yeah and we see magnus
there he is going to take some time
uh to see to calculate the line with
g4 let's go back uh briefly again to
prague and karana because you're just
showing the very nice move queen d8
before that you were also talking about
the possibility of queen e1 here
both moves win both moves win
essentially on the spot it's
uh black is spoiled for choice and you
might say well why is fabi taking so
long well again he doesn't know that
both moves win on the spot he's trying
to find the most accurate option uh he
doesn't want to let
prague off the hook
um probably the computer-ish option is
to play queen e1 and again the point of
this move
isn't to go well it is to go for chuck
may black threatens queen h4 and queen
g4 but if the king escapes then there's
this idea of h4 followed by h3 and black
is just gonna make a second queen
uh it's as simple as that look at this
bishop on a1 that is really what kills
white that bishop is just staring at its
own pawn without the pawn on e5 white
would have a lot more practical chances
uh a classic example of your own pawns
hurting him
for sure i mean for a while here
prague would have given a lot to just
say to fabiano take that pawn can we
just get it off the board
because right please
yeah it really was um
[Music]
making giving him zero counter play if
the bishop at least was active but stuck
on a2 but it was stuck on a2 and impeded
by its own
uh pawn and if you look at prague
uh he also
you got a feel for prague when you look
at him there
yeah i mean he's just sitting there
suffering he's waiting for fabi to find
inevitably find the winning move
and fabi could end up taking 25 minutes
here i mean
i don't think he will but that's one of
the hardest
experiences to just sit there and wait
for your 2800 opponent to
to find the winning move
yeah that's why
yeah
if fabiano very likely he might see
queen d8 and queenie one and he's gone
38 and dania
this is going to spell the end of the
game here
yes that's it um prague might resign
here he might make a couple more moves
the problem is that he loses the pawn on
c4 and with that pawn
i mean the whole position topples over
he's probably going to go king h4 king
ju1 king h2k1 queen takes c4 you know
what makes this completely indefensible
is the fact that white doesn't even have
an inkling
of a chance for a perpetual check if
white could somehow get the queen into
the game uh into the into the action
okay at least prague would keep playing
but the problem is
if you consider this line after queen
takes a one queen f6 show it might look
like white's got perpetual but he
doesn't the king very easily sidesteps
all of all of the checks
yeah and uh
we in the eighth prague
i agree with you might just resign or
might play king h2 and resign once c4
drops
yeah
and yeah such as life a rough game for
for uh prague really rough losing with
white
i think he was hoping at one point for
the repetition and maybe it was slightly
better
at some point but again missing that
chance to go after fabi's king
yeah maybe we can quickly bring that
position up where you were saying
there might be some knight d4 on the
cards bring the pieces closer towards
the enemy uh king but that
opportunity was left unused
so this is where fabi declined the
repetition he goes rook c8 prague
responds very well 95 is nice
queen c2 is good aiming for the for the
h7 square
knight e2 is good everything he did here
is good even though the computer
initially disapproves of it and now this
is the moment of truth he had to get
that knight over to g3
and then swing the rook from d4 to g4
and
you can see that the email bar actually
starts going into white's favor this is
a very dangerous position for fabi
uh but prague going in the other
direction knight t4 and i think i'm
gonna interrupt this we have an
interview
oh
not
not yet apparently not yet uh yet i just
thought you were oh now we do
all right let's pan out
jordan from forest uh you just beat
anish giri
with a beautiful game from start to
finish
yeah i'm very happy and pleased with the
game
i wanted to go for a fight today um
um
after my
loss two days ago so
um i thought let's let's give it a try
and i played a very risky line but i
thought um it might give white good
chances for for a good fight as well
um
on twitter i saw like a post by ivan
sokolov he was very happy because
you played a line that was recommended
in his course uh was it part of your
preparation i really looked at his uh
his court sure i think we even had a
conversation uh maybe in uh sweden
couple of months ago where he said he
thinks the line is uh
very nice for white so um
um
definitely uh uh well i mean i've been
looking at the line for uh for a bit
longer but his uh
his course was definitely a bit of help
at least yeah so then there was like
this moment um where you could actually
do the exchange sacrifice on f6 already
on move 15. you decided to do it to move
16. uh why did you choose to do it on 15
and not on 16.
yeah there were some concrete uh reasons
i thought it's um
with his pawn on c5 i get this nice bind
with all the pawns in the in the middle
of the board wires whereas if his pawn
is on c7 he can often for example
quickly transfer his knight from b7 to
c5 um so i didn't think it was so clear
there i mean i wasn't even sure how
clear it was
in the game but as it turns out it was
probably a very good uh for white always
where did it go wrong for anish
yeah maybe actually c5 is a mistake
because this allows the rook exchange
sacrifice in a much better version so
instead he had a lot of different
interesting options after which the game
would have been completely unclear
later on i thought he could have
defended better had he not played king
g7 but maybe played knight b7 but i
guess his position was
problematic in any case already
and then the final move rook h3 what a
beauty yeah but actually i wasn't sure
how to like completely break through he
was defending very uh resiliently and
then i spotted this rook h3 and i
thought um it's very risky of course but
um i should just take my time and
calculate and if it works it's
immediately winning so that's why i did
it yeah
anish was
in the race for for first place the door
is closed now
i guess
how
what are your emotions after after this
game and like
uh in regards to the tournament
standings and you're your own tournament
um yeah i was really just trying to at
least uh
like uh i want to finish my own
tournament in a in a in a good way so
it's uh it's a pity for anish that he uh
uh i'm not sure if he's still in the
race or or not um but uh
oh yeah i just wanted to play an
interesting interesting game so i was
just focusing on my own tournament is it
special to play anish
um
well i i mean um like um so let's say
growing up i i um
i really wanted to play like magnus and
anish always so definitely it is always
special as well to play uh anishi was
like top 10 already when i was basically
just starting out playing chess so i
remember the first game we played in
reykjavik 2017 it was um
definitely very special moment for me
and
we're good friends and i learned a lot
from him so i definitely always special
game with him um
how does this game rate in your best
game collection
i have to think about that but i am for
now i'm very happy with it yeah sure was
the perfect game for your side sorry it
was a perfect game from your side
i mean i have to analyze it um but
i i guess it's very unlikely that it was
perfect i was kind of upset when i took
an e5 i was
releasing the tension in the center i
could have played rook b1 immediately
but back then i wanted to sacrifice the
exchange and um then i thought a bit
more about it i thought it's not so
clear but i didn't know what else to do
and then play rook p1 anyway so um i
think that's like already a mistake by
me has to be checked of course but um
yeah in general very pleased with the
game
uh two more rounds to go
yeah um let's see how it goes i was
surprised i saw duda made a quick draw
with white today i think i'm playing him
tomorrow with black as well
so but usually he's going for big fights
so that's going to be extremely tough
but i'll just give it my best shot and
see what happens okay i wish you all the
best thank you
jordan van perry's clearly very happy of
course with his win against anisha as he
said they are great friends so he feels
sorry of course for a niche for whom
it's at the end i think of his hopes for
a tournament victory here but of course
he is trying to get his best he has his
best interests at heart dania you can't
have too many considerations for your
friends over the world
yeah for sure and you know he he was
being modest but this definitely will
have a prominent place in the best games
of eurodon vent forest to be published
at the end of his career in 2016.
um and fabi by the way
a good practical chance by prague he's
played f4
uh in order to create the e4 escape
square for his king now the fastest path
to victory for fabi is to give a check
on h4
and then you know the transformation
that we are familiar with giving up a2
in return for a decisive attack on the
king now the key thing that he has to
see here
is the maneuver of the knight from h4
to f5 this attacks e3 and this is
totally devastating black white loses
all of his pawns because the queen is
unable to defend that pawn while
while uh defending the bishop at the
same time white has to escape with the
king
and now queen takes e3 king c2 and the
simplest is just queen takes f4 and
everything collapses white we'll lose g2
as well and why we'll lose the game
that's a a stunning little move knight
f5
um but fabi once again he has so much
time on the clock i i think there's a
very good chance dania we will go down
this this exact line
yeah he's down to 38 minutes i mean
taking a lot of time on every move just
hammering it all out making sure he's
not allowing any counter play
i i think this is a very realistic thing
to see i mean
he understands that this is an idea to
give up the pawn
there are other enticing moves there's
the move queen g3 for example
after king f2 queen b1 is another thing
that i noticed
the only
roadblock
here is that after okay white just uh
keeps the status quo how what is the
finishing blow here what is the
finishing touch
uh still has to be found so queen h4 is
more accurate
yeah queen h4
um
the move we expect a move that fabiano
is calculating maybe we can quickly
update uh magnus carlsen against uh
vidit where with it a couple of moves
ago we thought maybe he'll play g6 he
went [ __ ]
now
maybe now
well king f7 is
possible but
probably not necessary
because there's a cool line here so in
this position
white can play king e7
and uh black
has to give this check and what's a very
important detail after king d6 you
cannot give the check because again
white builds the bridge but of course
black wins the game
with king takes f5 and uh a skewer
so white can still draw with king f8
uh rook d2 rook f7 but fiona this gets
messy white takes on g7 and avid has
absolutely no need to allow this i mean
he can't allow it and he'll still make a
draw but i really don't see any
downsides to the move g6 i i i failed to
see
what it is that you know magnus gains
from inducing g6 and i feel like this
will force the draw
more efficiently i mean rookie 6 b3
and if magnus takes on g6 here then
he'll only end up with a worse position
after b6 a5 and already here white might
be losing there's just no way to stop
the progress of the a pawn so magnus
kind of you can see him waiting for
vivid to inevitably play this move yeah
exactly magnus he knows that if uh vidit
finds
either g6 which probably is an immediate
row king f7 probably good enough and
this is over but um with it you're
always bobby
fabby sorry to interrupt you he's going
down that line wow
beautiful technique by fabi
really really incredible stuff here with
uh prague um
hasn't taken on a2 yet but what else
i mean he has to take that a2 you can
give one spike check on b8 that's not
going to do anything
i was thinking about queen b-8 check i
was just toying with some funny lines f5
but here it's simply knight h4 black
doesn't even need to take anything queen
b1 check king f4
queen f1 check look at that geometry
king e4 queen takes f5 as mate
and king g5 the queen corners the king
and checkmates it on g4
many many such lines the knight and the
queen is among the deadliest
peace tandems probably the deadliest
peace in all of chess and that's on full
display here
for sure and we see prague has just
captured on a2 and fabiano after
uh what has been a disappointing
event uh for him today here he is really
being clinical
in the end and tomorrow he will have
a game which uh can redeem pretty much
anyone's tournament if he can beat
magnus tomorrow he will be uh he might
be forgetting about the started event
huge huge huge game tomorrow against uh
magnuson and
i really wonder if fabi will
i mean i'm not necessarily expecting
fabi to go crazy
you know it's entirely possible that we
have a berlin and we have a quick draw
but i i think that phabby is going to
sense he's going to get a win today
and you know with only two games left
this as you said is a chance to redeem
his tournament if he beats magnus
everything is forgotten if you beat the
world champion uh nobody remembers how
you did in the other games everybody
remembers that you beat the world
champion
for sure and here well knight f5 is the
move you've already put the arrow on the
board
that is the move we're expecting and
that will be
very likely the last move of the game is
as you said white cannot defend
there
do you know what he just did there
the sip of water
yes do you know what that means it's
over
it's yeah exactly
i'm getting ready for my life
there's just you just like you if your
position is bad you're just not thinking
about
drinking water or eating or very often
uh if there's a granola bar or something
by your table you're only going to eat
it if you're like happy with the outcome
of the opening
at least that's true with me like i
never eat at the border drink of the
board unless i'm satisfied with that
position what is it some kind of
self-punishment
right well it's also like you you feel
like you haven't deserved it yeah i
guess it is kind of so funny i don't
know what fabby's thinking i really
don't know what he's thinking about i
mean just five is it's really the only
move in the position
um now that you've played knight h4
especially yeah now that he's gone down
the whole the whole line
and i think he's getting ready there we
go
he was just savoury he was just savoring
the moment you know and magnus i think
is watching from a distance
i think that's nice vivid has just made
a move
is it it's hard to make out from this
angle
he's played g6 that's it that ends it
yeah i was saying like i expect knight
f5 and a resignation here and then the
magnet escape but who knows maybe
magnus's game when will end even sooner
as fabi
is just reaching out
and he has played
not known
what
i mean i'm sure this is also winning on
the spot yeah this is also this just is
winning actually
this move is just as winning it's in
zugswang why doesn't zugs on
uh white doesn't have us look at this
look at the king white doesn't have a
single
move with any of his pieces i mean i
think the only thing i see
is bishop c3 but now knight f5 results
in checkmate this might even be better
than knight f5 knight g3 is unstoppable
mate
amazing i mean fabby is just a monster
queen this is why this is number two in
the world
queen episode
huh
sorry i keep currently
number four maybe
four
yeah currency number four
well he lost to some beginners in the
u.s championship that did you know that
knocked him off that knocked him off in
order to
[Laughter]
that was actually also i think i was
commentating actually
on that uh on that game which was a nice
a nice effort by the streamer who shall
remain unnamed
arrogant arrogant commentator can't miss
a single opportunity to obnoxiously
remind the crowd of who he beat in the
last tournament
it's un intolerable i mean does he have
to mention it every single time
that fabiano's name is brought up jeez
[Laughter]
and uh here well prague
for him
unfortunately today not his day but no
matter what happened i mean he had to
win against nils and especially the the
win against vidit from two days ago
which he i think will never be
forgetting
yeah and there is a
resignation
um beautiful job by fabiano what a game
no i mean this was really the end of
this was a an absolute masterpiece and
uh the king ending the game on e4 in the
center of the world
uh but for fabi good on him in the early
stages we thought this might end in a
repetition
but he played on and was rewarded with a
full point here against prague
definitely worried about
coming to g4 but
after prague played played 94th i
thought that's
my position my position was better and i
was pretty happy with my technique the
rest of the game
uh i'm sure we'll hear something like
that in the interview and car 1 is still
not having a great event but as we
discussed tomorrow's game with magnus is
going to be huge and on that note let's
switch on over
to the last remaining game of the day
what a day a quick day it's been in
rookie six this one is hurtling toward
its conclusion and fiona rookie six is
essentially a draw offer because vidit
is going to play b3 magnus is going to
wait one second tanya for the board to
be brought up here oh yeah yeah my bad
there we go so ricky six has been played
by magnus vidic is going to play b3
magnus is going to take on a6 after b2
rook b6
simply king f7 and neither side can do
anything to unlock either of the kings
and the funny thing is with it we
haven't seen him look so relaxed all day
long it's been it's been a tough game
but now finally life is good
the one thing you don't want to do is go
a5 this is really the only way to lose
the game because of rook f6 and king e7
and obviously
okay rook d2
rook d6
so
what is the difference you may ask why
do why is it so important to play you
through well if white goes for this
after rookie two check rookie 6
takes takes b2
the pawns promote simultaneously and
white doesn't have any any checkmate the
king has too much space
on the king side bit it just double
triple checking making sure
that there are no shenanigans there
yeah but b3 the move that we expect and
then i think magnus will also not be
interested in spending more time than
necessary on this game so after b3 i
think it will all end very very quickly
for me or not
yeah i guess that rook f6 check can be
thrown in and then he can take on a6 but
that doesn't actually change anything b2
ultimately the rook has to go and stop
the pawn
and then black moves in with king f7 and
toggles between
f8 and f7 white can play g4 g5 and this
can be added in
uh just
you know for fun
but that's it
and then as you say there's really
there's just a deadlock it feels like
fidet is getting ready
to make a move yeah that hand is
twisted toward bethlehem yeah it's
inexorably moving toward the b-pawn
he's just i mean against anybody else i
can guarantee you even in this
tournament
he would oh
nice camera angle there he would he
would have played b3 five minutes ago
against magnus you have such paranoia
that
you know you're going to let the win
you're going to let the draw slip that
you know he's checking this a billion
times over
yeah and really once again that is just
the effect that magnus has as well i
think
um
no other player in the world has that
sort of power over over his opponents
for sure
and uh well
still deep in thoughts
what do you think how long until he
plays b3
you know it might actually be 20 minutes
you know i
i don't know i feel like i feel like
that from my perspective there's nothing
to calculate it's really an incredibly
simple line and it's the only move
otherwise every other move is ridiculous
self-sabotage
but i don't blame him he's playing
magnus you don't want to squander a win
why you want to play too quickly against
banks got 30 minutes on the clock
i think i think it'll be faster than 20
minutes
i think so too i think he's and there is
the stare that's always one of the signs
and by the way very soon we'll be
hearing uh from fabian although he's
gotten some we've gotten some first
insights already
yeah i mean the tournament hasn't gone
too well for me but i was quite happy
just to score the win today
let's go to to the other faviano
all right
caruana you just beat prague with the
black pieces
um
how did the game go
i think i was a little bit worse out of
the opening he played a uh
rare but not entirely new idea to play
a4 and
after a5 we get very
a very known type of position but uh
these pawns create some potential
squares on b5 for him and on b4 for me
but
it's maybe a little worse but it's more
or less a normal position
then we were kind of shuffling around
and he went for a very ambitious idea in
95 but i thought it's a little bit
maybe you can ask questions about that
because like i think like you were
actually like repeating some moves were
you intending to like if you would
repeat most would you go for a draw well
i sort of avoided the repetition with
rook c8
i could have um kept playing bishop
before bishop d6 and
uh i i assume actually that he would
have continued playing but
um
i i didn't want to leave it to chance
that the game ends immediately and
of course the draw is isn't bad but it
would be a little bit
uh too
short of a draw so i played rook c8 to
sort of avoid that and also to provoke
him into some potential stuff like this
and yeah at some point it just went very
uh quickly downhill from him for him
after he played knight d4 which i think
was a very large mistake
um he could take on b5 queen d3 and i
think it's
it's very close to equal of course i'm
comfortable i certainly can't be worse
but uh i doubt i'm really better and um
yeah i don't know how bad it was for him
after 94 but it was extremely unpleasant
and the end game um i think is losing
although it's it's a little bit close
it's kind of concrete that i i never
let him get my a pawn just tactically he
never is able to get it and it advances
all the way to a2
um
[Music]
yeah earlier in disturbance he had some
struggles for example like with your
coach who was um
encouraging uh i think he's uh he's
released now from from that um
does it make you feel better here and
they can say no now everything is like
also like things reopened here yeah
it does feel a lot better especially now
that restaurants have opened like the
last two days
and things are seem more or less back to
normal
um but yeah it's a bit late in the
tournament for me i mean i have i have
no chances
of even uh fighting for first place uh
and i haven't okay already for a while
you know um haven't had any chances so
it's a bit like i'm i'm not really
playing for anything
but uh okay my play was terrible and at
least today i think it was normal so
that's uh that's a step up
um like my play for i don't know pretty
much the entire tournament up to this
round was was really really awful
even the games i won were were pretty
bad
so uh we will play magnus tomorrow yeah
i'll play magnus who i think is kind of
securing tormund victory no matter what
happens
if this game ends in a draw today
um then uh rapport will be half point
behind him ah okay i guess there's still
but he he also
has an automatic win in the last round i
mean it's
it's
it's like um yeah i guess it's
theoretically possible but it's pretty
hard to imagine any anything else
besides magnus winning the tournament at
this point
but like
is it like a special game for you to to
play
magnus someone you know very well yeah i
we we actually don't play quite as often
these days as we used to we used to play
you know a dozen times a year
um in various events in classical or
raptor blitz and
uh for whatever reason we haven't played
too much the last
like two years or so after we played
that online match um
on leach us
after that we really haven't played so
much so
uh yeah it's it's a bit uh
i guess it's somewhat special occasion
um
but yeah it's also we played so many
times against each other that doesn't
feel so special
okay well i wish you all the best thank
you thanks
fabiano they're saying what i think most
people are thinking magnus
his tournament is very close to being in
the back of course duboff sadly had to
drop out after testing positive and
dania you called it vidit might be
spending 20 minutes here he still hasn't
done b3
i would not not have had this level of
patience and i think magnus
you can kind of tell that he's getting
angsty
i just played b3 already kind of
expression
and
vidit is
you know i i i've never played magnus in
a classical game so i can't even really
imagine what he's experiencing and it's
this
it has to be just this paranoia that you
know that's
there's some trick there's some because
when you're playing magnus there's
always something it never is what it
seems except in this case it is what it
seems you know even the great magnus
he cannot move you cannot make an
illegal move so the king literally has
no squares
but video might take another
20 minutes i mean there's no no question
that
okay there he goes oh i can't
say that
but he's done that for the last 10
minutes he's literally like withdrawn
his hand from his
from the table and then put it back or
adopted a different thinking pose but i
think this time is about to be timing is
for real i think this time seems to be
for real yeah he's teasing us no there
we go again i'm telling you he's been
doing that for
for about 10 minutes
the hand has has come back indeed
i think okay i'm gonna say he will play
it within the next
before he hits 23 minutes on the clock
so in the next minute daniel is my call
yeah that's possible now the funny thing
is there's literally no other every
other move is absurd
every move other than b3 is absurd
uh including a5 which i think you might
have spent some time calculating maybe
even thinking about playing for a win
but
i mean it's a two move variation and the
game ends immediately
uh the point by the way here's rook d2
rook d6 i i didn't finish this line
earlier black can give rookie two check
white covers on e6 and of course now
black white can already promote and it
turns out that and there you were caught
right on the money
you were right on the money he's gone b3
and i think magnus is quickly going to
uh offer the peace accords
magnus not looking in in great shape
actually i don't know if it's the
frustration now that he i mean he's had
plenty of time all that time that fitted
has spent uh
in this but magnus i'm sure he wasn't
thinking about b3 he knew this is just a
draw now if it had placed b3 so he's had
plenty of time to to think about could
he have done something better before and
from his reaction right now to me it
seems like he's come to the conclusion
yeah there was a better try than this
indeed and now it's magnus's turn to
you know
to take his sweet time here before
taking the pawn on a6 which is what's
going to happen he's either going to do
it immediately or he's going to throw in
rook f6 check first the magnus move is
rook f6 jack first and then rook takes
a6 he plays clinically until the end
even when it doesn't really matter
and we see that village after making the
move he took his time but the way he's
walking around now is he knows magnus
knows and when both players know there
is not much
uh much left to play for
i expected
i don't fully understand why they're
taking as much time as they're taking
uh like because the only thing that
white can do i mean white can play rook
b6 oh no but then just b2 that's even
worse i guess what i meant to say is
rook takes g6 is the only move that
makes any uh visible impact on the
position but again b2
now you can throw in rook f6 check just
to get the king away and rook b6 this
does have to be calculated in particular
white can try pushing his pawns up the
board but a5 h4 a4 g5 and black comes
first after a3 black links up the pawns
after g6 checking g7 yeah finally white
is able to move his king away but rookie
to check rookie six and now watch this
take stakes b1 queen d8 queen and what
black forces the queen trade and wins
the game with queenie for check and
queen d4 check not that i mean this
isn't even close even if black didn't
have this black would have 50 other
moves
so
again not sure what it is that is
attracting magnus's attention here
i'm not sure what it is that makes
magnus look so distraught
here after after b3 it's such a strange
moment
to say he's also
like also magnus you're leading the
tournament
you're okay you know it's gonna be fine
uh danya we will leave magnus to it
we're gonna go on a very quick break of
course we'll keep the camera on the
players so you don't miss anything and
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the very final stages of
this round 11 here in tata steel uh jazz
tournament
and dania it took a while for us to get
there but uh now
the game really is well and truly over
and there is the handshake shake
a draw agreed and that they decided to
go into that queen end game
and what a save for vidit
he i mean recovering from that
incredibly painful loss
uh and that just shows you know his
resilience and strength of character in
nick's magnus for a draw but obviously
given that anish gary lost uh for magnus
this draw he's going to be disappointed
but this only extends his lead in the
tournament
for sure he
is now
still uh leading i think he's a point
clear we'll we'll see the standings in a
second anyway they're just being updated
now
but yeah for magnus in terms of
tournament standings it is a good result
a half a point he'll be half a point of
report so in terms of tournament
standings it is good news reminder that
um
well we'll wait we'll we'll talk about
that when the results are uh for now
we see a very animated discussion
between magnus and vidit
indeed and i think this is a good time
uh to take the opportunity to present to
you your round 11 rapid recap fiona and
i think there's really no question uh
which game
we would like to choose for the rapid
recap it is the absolutely incredible
display
uh
in the game event forest against geary
but i won't reveal who put this display
together for those just watching for the
first time
and it started off innocuously right
yes but it got crazy quickly
very soon as early as move
four a3 here dania and you're telling us
this is quite a rare guess at the
highest level
but a move that comes with a lot of
poison
it does this is called the sameish
variation it forces the trade on c3 and
the point is that yes white has
damaged his queen side pawn structure
but in return white occupies a massive
center of pawns f3 and e4 with anish
going for sort of the traditional way of
playing against this variation he goes
after this weak pawn on c4 with
everything
that he's got while jordan he tries his
best to defend that pawn and
simultaneously keep expanding in the
center
so that's what we see happening over the
next couple of moves queenie two over
protecting the pawn on c4 and after
anisha's next move d6 here comes jordan
taking some ground with f4
yeah this is a very nice multi-purpose
move first of all he expands in the
center but second of all most
importantly and and this is just
exquisite knight f3 and just in time he
brings the knight back to d2 defending
the c4 pawn one more time and anish just
runs out of pieces that he can use to
attack that pawn the knight on f6 has no
way of approaching the pawn and this is
where things started going south for
uh anish he starts by playing e5 he
strikes in the center
uh jordan responds with uh castle just
keeping the tension and fiona this was
quite possibly the most important moment
of the game absolutely a big critical
moment we were maybe expecting uh queen
size castles uh which doesn't look too
appealing at first sight but the problem
with the alternative of castling
kingside which is what anish ended up
doing it runs into a big attack
on the king side
it does jordan starts by opening up the
f-file and he had an immediate exchange
stack on f6 but he decided to throw in
the move rook b1
and it seems in retrospect that anish
should have taken this opportunity and
gotten his knight off of f6 although
after rook f3 followed by a rook lift
the position remains incredibly
dangerous
uh for black but gary maybe
in the center dania maybe we can just
show that one line if anish had
sacrificed immediately on f6 with this
incredible
f2 variation
yeah there was an unbelievable line
pointed out uh by some people queen f2
looks like a blunder right allows me to
one check okay you have to cover with
the bishop no you don't you can play
knight f1 looks like another blunder but
after uh queen h4 incredibly it turns
out that white has unstoppable threat
threats against black's king in
particular the threat is to play bishop
h6 follow up with queen takes f6 there's
going to be mate and the apocalypse is
going to happen on the dark squares
bishop takes c4 and just in time white
links up the rook in the night with mate
to follow but can you really blame
jordan for not seeing this particular
definitely not i think so
especially not as after he was given the
chance uh one more time after anisha's
move c5 now he decided
okay this time it is time and he went
for the exchange stack on f6
indeed and queen f2 was still possible
but jordan going for queen f3 also an
incredibly powerful attacking move
hitting anish where it hurts forcing the
queen back now jordan locks up the
position and immediately starts working
on activating all of his minor pieces
bringing all hands on deck we were
expecting him uh to swing the knight
around to h5 but he decided to keep his
knight on e3 and i was particularly
impressed with this idea using the
bishop fiona as the primary attacker of
this incredibly weak pawn on f6 indeed
and that bishop just maneuvered itself
over to h4 there was nothing black could
do
to stop it and here is maybe the moment
where the game was decided
yeah i mean anish had to bite the bullet
bring the knight back and just hunker
down in total passive defense is this
fun absolutely not and white has
multiple ways you can try to improve his
position in particular there's this idea
of bringing the bishop back to e2 and
then ultimately swinging it to h5 but
black can try to play queen d8 here
maybe bring the knight over to d6 he's
still in the game but aneesh kind of
reacted in a panicked way he went rook
h6
uh which ends up being an incredibly
costly waste of temple why because
jordan goes queen f2 a move that he
wants to play anyway because it paves
the way for the bishop to swing either
to g4 which would decisively weaken the
f5 square or
in some circumstances if the rook
returns to g6 the bishop can swing to h5
and essentially fiona that's exactly
what happened indeed we saw first the
rook come into the game black was forced
to play king g7 to defend
f6 and here comes that bishop
and now we see that anish has nothing
better than to go back to g6 anyway
yeah and here bishop h5 was possible
maybe even the most accurate but jordan
choosing an alternate alternate way to
prepare bishop g4
out of desperation in each place bishop
takes hp but the very prosaic reputation
bishop h5 and black is totally busted
here if rook h6
uh then among other things white can
just take on h3 take on f6
and now get this king out of the way and
there's going to be
uh just decisive stuff happening on the
g file uh anish decided to give away
this rook on g6 and then the pulse pawn
falls and fiona we were just very
impressed with the way that uh jordan
took this all the way to the full point
it was i mean uh very clever i mean
possibly a perfect uh performance bayern
who brought the queen and now queen
h4 and um
the attack just continues rolling you're
also pointing out jordan doesn't need to
find an immediate mate because black is
just tied down there is nothing he can
do
indeed and you can see jordan keeps
tightening the screws and now he hits
the e5 phone it cannot be defended he
takes that pawn off the board and he
tries to get his knife back into the
game but to no avail the queen drops
back to f4 paving the way for these two
connected passers to march
all the way forward e5 d6 and now he's
got the d5 square for his knight and in
this position they're approaching time
control jordan not taking his foot off
the gas pedal here comes the knight
and uh and he's trying to use this queen
as some sort of a decoy and after 97
checking h8 uh the final sort of
sparkling idea to cap off the game fiona
was absolutely brilliant final move with
the game indeed and that move is rook h3
a rook sacrifice at first sight but the
problem is if black were to capture now
we see that that was actually a decoy
and d7 appears on the board with uh
unsolvable back rank issues
indeed if queen takes d7 queen beatrix
wins the queen with checkmate to follow
and perhaps the most beautiful line if
rook f8 happens now black takes his eyes
off of the g7 square and white smashes
down the pawn on g6 with queen h6 queen
g7 mate and if the king moves to g8 the
simplest win is just to take the rook
and then to give that aforementioned
check on b8 followed by
making a second queen anish having
calculated these lines decided not to
continue the game and resigned on move
42. yordman forest not only the winner
of last year's status still showing that
that was far from a fluke beta nishikiri
i think in the armageddon and he defeats
him again this tournament jordan
benforce what an impressive young man
what an impressive game a stunning game
against a niche well probably one of his
best wins this was your rapid recap of
the day hope you enjoyed that game and
uh dania it's been a strange day but
here here are the results of this round
11.
yeah as we can see we've got three
decisive results could have been four
due to shanklin and in a quick draw as
did mahmud yarov karjakin and
carlson he's going to be kicking himself
he had some chances against fitted but
ultimately
uh the the indian player uh put together
a wonderful resistance pulling out the
drop fabiano with a great game against
prague report of course winning by
default sad news as duboff uh has to
drop out of the tournament due to covet
and jordan of course as we just saw
defeating anish giri let's have a look
at the standings so for the standings
what this means is magnus carlsen
uh he is half a point clear at the top
but remember he was scheduled to play
duboff at uh during the last round which
uh is a point he's going to get by walk
over so as long as he ends uh tomorrow's
day with
that same half a point lead the
tournament will be decided um but
rapport
he is still in pursuit and now let's
look at the all-important pairings the
tournament victory will be decided
between these two but magnus he has one
final test as he has the black pieces
against none other than fabiano carrana
tomorrow
dude that's a very difficult final boss
and fabby will do everything he can
to finish the tournament in style and of
course we see some other really cool
matchups and rapper that will be the
other huge game of course he will try to
go
for the full point that's for certain
with the black pieces against andreas
panko we've seen him play some very
enterprising chess this tournament as
always um and
i expect more of the same
tomorrow elsewhere
what do we have well first quick look at
the schedule so two rounds to go
tomorrow's will uh tomorrow's one will
start at the usual time
of at 2 p.m
central european time
that's 5 a.m pacific and the last round
though so first reminder uh the last
round will start two hours early at noon
central european time that's 3 a.m
pacific quite an early start on the on
the
west coast there danya
absolutely um and it's eight eastern for
me and you certainly do not want to miss
it these are the all-important last two
rounds of
the tournament and what around it was
today this has not disappointed we've
had so much action so much so much cool
stuff today was a relatively quicker day
tomorrow is going to be another grind
and uh
it'll be an amazing start to the weekend
but fiona this was once again so much
fun these hours always fly by absolutely
and it is the final weekend last two
rounds
don't miss the round tomorrow because it
could be that the tournament is decided
then i know we're still waiting we're
not gonna stick around if we haven't
raided yet we will end the day if magnus
comes in soon then we'll jump there for
now we are going to to call it a day
because we don't know is he coming or
not keep an eye out on the youtube
channel of tata steel chess if we don't
play an interview here but magnus
gives one you can find it there dany i'm
losing my
losing my footing yeah we'll take some
rest and we'll see everybody tomorrow
thank you so much to everybody for
watching fiona uh always a pleasure and
thank you to big for another excellent
pleasure is mine daniel tomorrow
see you tomorrow have a good one
bye
[Music]
london system on the board
yes and it should play pretty quickly
not to lose the time advantage as we
know that players are getting in
increment only on move 60.
magnus carlsen just played a draw with
feed it and just before the interview
you asked me like did i miss a win i let
you check with the computer and what is
the answer yeah i guess i did it wasn't
very very obvious
but
yeah i guess that was the the moment i
uh
should have taken more time to uh to
think uh but easy yeah
um it was like the moment with like rook
e7 instead of d7 right
yeah
um
i'm still trying to to wrap my hand
around it a little bit um
there were
i mean a couple was um
before of course i thought it was a
pretty uh pretty dead draw um
it wasn't even wasn't even clear i was
gonna i was gonna try uh but yeah this
knight d5 and
were you surprised by the by the night
trade uh yeah no i was pretty sure he'd
missed this rookie one idea
yeah that was um was obviously a
pleasant
pleasant surprise um
yeah clearly i um
could have uh could have spent some some
more time there that was um that was a
bit unfortunate i thought
um
i didn't have any other moves there and
uh if there were chances i'll i'd look
for them later but maybe they were
yeah they were there they were right
there yeah um it's quite a weird day um
which might actually turn out
to be very well for your chances to win
the tournament um duboff this is
positive
which will have the anti-climax in the
last round where you don't play a game
jordan beat anish geary
um yeah sure
i'm more concerned about my my own
performance to be honest so um
today wasn't um
wasn't great
so
but yeah obviously i got
got very um
very lucky with uh other
with circumstances that were out of my
my control um i just hope that daniel is
doing fine uh it
seemed this morning that he was feeling
okay and i really really hope he can
make it to um to berlin for for the
grand prix um
i think that's uh
that's the
the tournament was kind of rain for him
anyway but that's i think his biggest
priority as well is obviously
staying relatively healthy yeah um
tomorrow you will play your last game of
the tournament um against fabiana
caruana
it's going to be quite a big
big game to close the tournament yeah uh
it's going to be a big game tomorrow of
course um
i thought fabi played
after
after a while uh a really um interesting
game today uh against prague uh i
thought like for um a brief moment in
the opening he was
considerably worse um
but
it passed and
then um he went on to win a nice game
any any comments on the jordan 5 race
game today yeah uh sure
i wasn't very happy as
[Music]
you know somebody who's
competing for tournament victory after
after the
after
before i'd made any any of my moves he'd
already played
the sameish but um yeah you gotta say he
played um he played a
a very good game as far as i could um
as far as i could see and
yeah close to show he is um
his top level is very very high
you can play some some awesome games and
happy frame oh thank you and all the
best tomorrow thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you